foreign
welcome back to our Channel where we
delve into the interviewing world of
technology and Security today we are
embarking on an exciting journey to
explore the fascinating realm of cyber
security fundament in this video we'll
uncover some mind-blowing facts and
insights that will not only pick your
curiosity but also Empower you to
navigate the digital landscape securely
if you are an inspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certifications from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility
then search no more simply lands
postgraduate program in cyber security
from MIT University in collaboration
with EC Council should be a right choice
that is designed to accommodate a
diverse range of Learners and this
course required just a bachelor degree
with a 50 average and no prior
programming experience work history
needed for more details you can use the
link mentioned in the description box
below and if you're dreaming of earning
prestigious cyber security certificates
like cissp CH or CompTIA Security Plus
this program is your ticket to success
we offer a cyber security expert
master's program that is designed to
accommodate a diverse range of Learners
and it requires no prior programming
experience or work history our program
not only equips you with essential cyber
security skills but also prepares you
for the industry's most esteemed
certifications making you an expert in
the field
and now let's hear from our Learners
about their personal experience and
their success story after graduating
from the simply learns postgraduate
program in cyber security from MIT
University hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years
old and last year iopskill with simply
learns post program in cyber security
after working 30 years in the IIT sector
in various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and ccsp certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course course I must say was packed
with practical examples it was led by
highly skilled certified instructors I
worked with many companies before the
security analysts and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course first and foremost I've
been a learner be a learner first
meet Anne
she often shops from
www.shoppingcart.com
she has her information like email ID
address and credit card details saved on
the website to enable a faster and
hassle-free shopping experience
the required information is stored in a
server one day and received an email
which stated her eligibility for a
special discount voucher from
shoppingcard.com in order to receive the
coupon code she was asked to fill in her
shopping cart.com account credentials
this didn't seem fishy to her at the
time as she thought it was just an
account verification step little did she
realize the danger she would be facing
she was knocked off her feet when a
substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account
how do you think this happened well yes
the email she received was Faye and
shoppingcart.com account witnessed
unauthorized access from a third party
this type of attack is known as a Cyber
attack and the person who carries it out
is called a hacker could Anne have
prevented this attack
indeed she could have with the help of
cyber security
cyber security involves techniques that
help in securing various digital
components networks data and computer
systems from unauthorized digital access
there are multiple ways to implement
cyber security depending on the kind of
network you are connected to and the
type of cyber attacks you are prone to
so let's take a look at the various
cyber attacks that Anne could have been
exposed to one of the most common types
of cyber attacks is a malware attack
like Trojan adware and spyware to name a
few had and downloaded any suspicious
attachments online her system could have
gotten corrupted by certain malicious
viruses embedded within the attachments
next is a phishing attack the type of
Cyber attack which Anne experienced here
the hacker usually sends fraudulent
emails which appear to be coming from a
legitimate Source this is done to
install malware or to steal sensitive
data like credit card information and
login credentials
another type of attack is the man in the
middle attack
here the hacker gains access to the
information path between Anne's device
and the website server the Hacker's
computer takes over Anne's IP address by
doing so the communication line between
Ann and the website is secretly
intercepted
this commonly happens with unsecured
Wi-Fi networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system here Anne's
password could have been cracked by
using either common passwords or trying
all possible alphabetical combinations
to prevent future cyber attacks and
sought to implement a few cyber security
practices
first she installed a firewall as the
name suggests it is a virtual wall
between Ann's computer and the internet
firewalls filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
Hardware reinforcements secondly an
implemented honey pots just like how
flowers attract bees dummy computer
systems called honeypots are used to
attract attackers these systems are made
to look vulnerable in order to deceive
attackers and this in turn defends the
real system in addition to these she
also decided to use unique alphanumeric
passwords antivirus software and started
avoiding males from unknown senders that
was Anne's story
cyber attacks are not just confined to
individuals but also to public and
private organizations the cyber attacks
carried out in such places are more
deadly and they result in colossal
losses
motives of such attacks are many
starting from tampering with crucial
data to monetary gains let's have a look
at a few of the cyber attacks that
companies are subjected to
various public sector organizations and
large corporations face the advanced
persistent threat apt
in this form of attack hackers gain
access to networks for a prolonged
period in order to continuously gain
confidential information
companies also witnessed the denial
service attack where networks are
flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service DDOS
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack
when a hacker manipulates a standard SQL
query in a database driven website it is
known as a SQL injection attack by doing
so hackers can view edit and delete
tables from databases amidst a plethora
of cyber attacks it is indeed a
challenge for organizations with several
networks and servers to ensure complete
Security this is not an easy task and to
help with this cyber Security
Professionals are hired to work on
identifying cyber threats and securing a
company's Network
there are multiple job roles in the
field of cyber security if hacking
fascinates you then the role of an
ethical hacker is something to be
explored
such professionals try to Network's
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do but only to identify those
vulnerabilities and resolve them for
protection against an actual Cyber
attack but if you are looking to design
robust security structures then the role
of a security architect is more apt a
chief information security officer ciso
plays a crucial role in Enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization well there are several
reasons as to why you should learn cyber
security here we have the top 10 reasons
for the same
at number 10 the reason we have is basic
requirements there is a wrong notion
that building a career in cyber security
is daunting
well it is not
a fancy college degree is not at all
that it takes to become a successful
cyber security professional
you can Venture into the domain of cyber
security with some basic knowledge of
I.T and with an authorized cyber
security certification the overall
eligibility Criterion for the cyber
security domain is relaxing across the
world
it professionals with cyber security
certifications are known to receive
higher salary packages
certifications are always given extra
weightage in the infosec field and it
opens dose to bigger opportunities
these cyber security certifications can
be opted by anyone as the eligibility
for these are very basic cyber security
certifications trained professionals and
thus helps in Bridging the Gap between
the supply and demand of skilled cyber
Security Professionals
so don't take a step back from learning
cyber security thinking it is a tedious
process if you are a fresher or a
professional you can go ahead with just
these basic requirements
before moving on to our next reason here
is a question for you all
how many of you like mathematics please
let us know in the comment section below
I'm sure not everyone loves mathematics
and that is completely okay when it
comes to learning cyber security
and our ninth reason is mathematics is
not a concern for learning cyber
security
many of us find mathematics challenging
some have the aptitude for dealing with
numbers and some don't
and for those who don't they find it
difficult to proceed with a career that
has maths involved
however you can take your decision
without any worries when it comes to
cyber security as the domain of cyber
security does not involve mathematics
so if maths is not your strong point
then choosing to learn cyber security is
a great choice
this can definitely be a relief to many
instead you can get acquainted with
networking network security control and
coding to build a career in cyber
security
our eighth reason is that cyber security
is a profession that helps achieve the
greater good
cyber security consists of a set of
measures and approaches that help
companies and individuals data from
being compromised and stolen
cyber Security Professionals have
defended organizations from several
deadly cyber attacks that aimed at
jeopardizing an organization's
confidentiality integrity and
availability
cyber crimes are currently on their eyes
but different types of cyber attacks the
threat to organizations and individuals
alike is only growing by the day
government agencies police forces and
cyber crime cells are tackling this
threat however there is more requirement
for skilled cyber security professionals
who can protect data and work for the
greater good
therefore if you want to bring about a
positive impact and a meaningful
difference to the society we live in
then learning cyber security is a great
choice our seventh reason is that you
get to travel the world
who doesn't love to travel the globe
learning cyber security is a great
reason especially for those of you who
aspire to travel the world
with the lack of cyber Security
Professionals in the world there are
plenty of opportunities for skilled
experts to travel overseas to Showcase
their cyber security skills which are in
high demand
The increased demand for cyber Security
Professionals is not just restricted to
one area but to the entire world
there are several employment
opportunities for cyber Security
Professionals across the globe so
learning cyber security can open new
doors for you overseas as well our sixth
reason is very interesting and that is
the fact that you get to work with
secret agencies and high profile ones
like other professionals
cyber Security Professionals also have
the opportunity to work with several
prestigious multinational companies and
big giants like Google Dell Accenture
and others however a cyber security
professional's career opportunities can
go beyond mncs and they might get the
opportunity to work with top government
secret agencies like Mossad NSA Nia FBI
and so on
so what are you waiting for become a
cyber security expert and showcase your
skills to grab the chance to work with
these top agencies our fifth reason is
it is never too late to begin with
there are very few professions that give
you the Liberty to begin late
and one such profession is cyber
security it is never too late to realize
that you want to become a cyber security
expert
many people work as cyber Security
Professionals even after the retirement
if they have a good knowledge about ID
you could also join cyber security
courses that train you irrespective of
your age
as long as you have good cyber security
skills there is no need to worry about
job security however late it is
our fourth reason is cyber security is
an evergreen industry
cyber security has gradually become an
evergreen industry
in the current times with the onset of
the covid-19 pandemic businesses are
moving online and shifting to cloud
storage the demand for cyber security is
at its peak
there is a high demand for cyber
Security Experts who can Safeguard
Digital Data hence we can't be rest
assured that cyber security is here to
stay and this domain is only going to
grow in the coming years
according to cyber security Ventures the
number of Internet users will hit a
whopping 6 billion by 2022.
these numbers speak volumes and this
reveals the growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
digitalization is taking place across
several Industries
a cyber security expert finds
opportunities in every field as every
organization wants to be secure on the
digital front so now is the right time
if you are looking to learn and start a
career in cyber security before moving
to our top three reasons to learn cyber
security here are some crucial
information for you all
as you know with relevant certifications
you can grow your cyber security career
and here we are to help you with that
you can check out Simply loans cyber
security export Masters program to equip
you with the necessary skills to become
an expert in this rapidly growing domain
training for highly sought after
certifications like CompTIA Security
Plus CH cism and cissp is at the
Forefront of this course preparing you
for the industry's best jobs
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and grow
your career in cyber security today
so our third reason to learn cyber
security is because of the plenty of job
opportunities it offers
according to the U.S Bureau of Labor
Statistics the employment of information
security analyst is projected to grow 33
percent from 2020 to 2030. much faster
than the average for all occupations
with the world turning digital that is a
dire need for companies to hire cyber
Security Experts who can protect and
Safeguard sensitive data as firms work
to improve their cyber security
structure they are also hiring several
cyber security exports to design
Implement and maintain the Cyber
Security Solutions
cyber security jobs are not limited to
the it domain many security positions
are found at companies outside of it
including Industries like Media Sports
or Finance to name a few
this emphasizes on the fact that cyber
security export is exposed to several
job opportunities from different types
of companies across the globe
our second reason for you to learn cyber
security is the good salary package it
offers
salaries play a crucial part in any job
that you undertake isn't it
every individual likes to get duly
rewarded for their work and cyber
security is one such domain that
provides fat paychecks
cyber security exports are the
individuals who have come to the rescue
with the unprecedented rise in cyber
crimes across the world organizations
are willing to pay Sky High salaries for
these cyber security exports
there is a lack of skilled cyber
Security Professionals and this is
another reason cyber security exposure
paid well
the salaries of cyber Security
Professionals are still expected to grow
in the coming times owing to the high
demand
salaries and cyber security have a high
growth potential and if you are a
skilled cyber security professional you
can always negotiate your salary
finally a top reason to learn cyber
security is that you will have a job
that never gets boring and a domain that
offers unlimited potential for personal
growth
several times individuals find
themselves lost in their career due to
lack of challenges due to their mundane
work and also due to stagnation at work
these reasons play a major role when it
comes to a professional quitting their
job however a job rule in cyber security
tackles these reasons to an extent and
that is why we have this reason at
number one
cyber security is a domain that is
constantly evolving and so are the
nature of cyber attacks hackers are
always trying to develop new methods to
get to your data
they develop new exploits regularly and
hence as a cyber security professional
you will face interesting challenges to
find Optimal Solutions for new exploits
you will have new puzzles to solve
a cyber security career is not going to
be stale
along with failures you will also be
exposed to new and interesting
discoveries
to keep yourself updated in this field
and to tackle cyber attacks you should
be in a position to outsmart the hackers
being in the field of cyber security
allows you to constantly upskill and
enhance your knowledge and experience it
also ensures that your Learning Journey
will never stop when the world churning
virtual cyber attacks are constantly
flooding new headlines covid-19
accelerated the current digital
transformation in the year 2020
witnessed several data breaches since
technology has become more intertwined
with our daily lives it is no surprise
that the need for skilled cyber Security
Professionals is increasing on that note
hey everyone welcome yet to another
exciting video by simply learn which
will take you through the top cyber
security career options available today
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the Subscribe button and that
Bell icon for interesting Tech videos
every day
there is a significant lack of skilled
cyber security professionals who can
tackle the cyber security challenges
faced daily hence a career in cyber
security is demanding and equally
rewarding finding the right career path
in the cyber security industry isn't
always easy here we are here to help you
with that there are a few prerequisites
for a career in cyber security the basic
one being a bachelor's degree in a
subject relating to cyber security
however if you don't have a relevant
degree you can always take up relevant
cyber security certifications and
Kickstart your cyber security Journey
a few other skills like networking
knowledge of operating systems and Cloud
security are required to start and grow
your cyber security career you can check
out our video on the top 5 cyber
security skills to know more
cyber security jobs vary from entry
level to Executive management and
everything in between there are several
cyber security paths available today it
is best if you start with entry level
and then move on to the next level with
the help of certifications and relevant
experience here let us have a look at
the top 5 cyber security job rules today
the first job role is that of a network
engineer Network Engineers construct and
administer a company's computer networks
they are responsible for installing
configuring and supporting Network
equipment they also configure and
maintain firewalls switches and routers
this entry-level cyber security job can
help you start your journey to become an
ethical hacker the annual average salary
of a network engineer in the US is 85
000 and 98 dollars and in India it is
around 510 000 rupees
second on our list is information
security analyst as an information
security analyst your primary duty is to
protect sensitive information
information security analysts create and
Implement plans for preventing cyber
attacks they monitor data access and
ensure compliance with policies
depending on the Cyber threat they
decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further in the US an
information security analyst earns eight
to nine thousand and one hundred forty
dollars annually and in India they earn
6 lakh 42 and 756 rupees
third on our list is ethical hacker they
are also known as penetration testers
they are Network Security Consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do they probe and test and network
using various penetration tools and
software they also design new
penetration tools and document the test
results in the US a certified ethical
hacker earns around ninety three
thousand dollars on an annual average
basis and in India they make around 5
lakh rupees the fourth job role that we
are going to talk about is security
architect
security Architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organizations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks a security
architect approves the installation of
routers VPN and firewalls their duties
go beyond just architecture building and
including formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides security
architects in the US make a handsome sum
of 124 thousand dollars a year on an
average and in India they make nearly 21
lakh 80 000 rupees and finally fifth on
our list is Chief Information Security
Officer ciso they are senior level
officers in an organization they ensure
the safety of the information they
develop Implement and maintain
information security and risk management
programs they also interact with
stakeholders and regularly brief them
with information security concerns the
average annual salary of a chief
information security officer in the
states is a whopping 165 thousand
dollars annually and in India it is 22
lakh 22 and 845 rupees several companies
are looking for skilled cyber Security
Professionals Philips Siemens Google
Microsoft and GE to name a few with
passion the right amount of experience
and relevant certifications you can grow
your cyber security career you can check
out Simply learned cyber security expert
Masters program to equip you with the
necessary skills needed to become an
expert in this rapidly growing domain
this course will help you learn various
methods as to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more according to cybercrime magazine by
cyber security Ventures globally there
would be nearly 3.5 million unfilled
cyber security jobs by 2021 and the
number of Internet users will hit a
whopping 6 billion by 2022.
these numbers speak volumes and this
shows the growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
now that you know the high demand for
cyber Security Professionals let us help
you start your cyber security career by
bagging the right skill set
many of you out there might be waiting
to become a cyber security professional
but are unsure of how to go about it and
what skills you would need to get a
cyber security job
not to worry we are here to help you
with that after extensive research we
have come up with the top five skills
that will help you get into the field of
cyber security let's have a look at
these skills individually
first we have networking and system
administration the number one skill you
need to have to enter the field of cyber
security is computer networking
networking is the backbone of the
internet it is imperative that you have
an in-depth understanding of networking
to start a career in cyber security a
network is a group of interconnected
devices and networking is the art of
understanding how data is sent
transmitted and received amongst these
devices
you need to know various routing
protocols the TCP and OSI models govern
networking The OSI model is
comparatively newer basically in these
models all the protocols are grouped
into layers and work together to help
you receive data on your device sent
from a server learning networking will
help you understand the technical
aspects of data transmission which will
help you secure your data you can take
up networking certifications like
Security Plus and Cisco CCNA to gain a
strong networking Foundation
another skill that will be beneficial
for you is to Master System
Administration
if you think about it all of us are CIS
admins at some level
system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features and settings
and play around a bit
carry out a trial and error method and
give yourself small tasks like
recovering deleted files or monitoring
old viruses on a VM explore new
techniques put them into use and expand
your knowledge
let us now move on to our second skill
knowledge of operating systems and
virtual machines
to become a cyber security professional
you need to have a strong knowledge of
operating environments such as Windows
Linux and Mac OS
cyber Security Professionals largely use
Linux and it comes with several tools
to learn operating systems go ahead and
set up and use Virtual machines that is
VMS and play around with them this will
help you gain hands-on experience
as a cyber security expert you should be
comfortable working on any OS
VMS allow you to train and research in
an isolated environment and help you
maximize your skills
the next point to remember is to know
Kali Linux
it is the most widely known Linux
distribution for ethical hacking and
penetration testing
it comes with several hundred tools
related to penetration testing malware
analysis security research computer
forensics and so on
Kali contains several projects and you
can learn a lot another good thing about
Kali is that it is free to use so what
are you waiting for download and start
right away
remember that Linux is the backbone of
cyber security and a commonly asked
topic for cyber security interviews
especially for pen testing roles
moving on to our third skill our third
skill is network security control
it is another basic skill that every
cyber security professional should have
network security control refers to the
different measures which are employed to
enhance the security of a network
it is simple you can only Safeguard your
network if you know how it works how
routers firewalls and other devices work
a firewall is a hardware or software
that blocks incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer
firewalls are required to secure a
network as a cyber security expert you
must be able to leverage a firewall to
filter and prevent unauthorized traffic
onto the network
in addition to that as a cyber security
expert you must know about intrusion
detection systems intuition prevention
systems virtual private networks and
remote access
and intrusion detection system IDs is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system
it is used together with a firewall and
a router
you should be able to operate the IDS
and recognize any security policy
violations and malicious traffic on the
network
as many of you may have used a VPN is a
connection between a VPN server and a
VPN client it is a secure tunnel across
the internet
moving on next up we have an interesting
skill any idea what that is if yes boss
and leave a comment as to what you think
the next skill will be
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
and before we jump into this skill if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up
fourth skill on our list is coding
so you might be wondering if coding is
really required to become a cyber
security professional well it is true
that not all cyber Security
Professionals have or need coding skills
however having zero coding knowledge May
limit your opportunities in the future
knowing a couple of programming
languages will help you identify the
plan behind an attack and defend against
deadly hacking techniques
so as seen on your screens these are the
best programming languages to learn to
make your cyber security career
worthwhile
we have C and C plus plus the C
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems C and C plus plus
are low level programming languages that
you need to know as a cyber security
professional
on the other hand python is a high level
programming language that is becoming
popular among cyber Security Experts
today knowing python will give you an
upper hand in your career it will help
you identify and fix vulnerabilities
JavaScript is another high level
programming language that adds
interactivity to web pages
a good advantage of knowing JavaScript
is that you can prevent cross-site
scripting attacks from occurring as in
these attacks the attacker implants
malicious code in a web application
speaking of PHP because most of the
websites are created using PHP learning
it will help you defend against
intruders
similarly HTML is another language cyber
Security Professionals should understand
as most websites use it and it is one of
the easiest languages to learn
another programming language that you
can use is golang it is great for
cryptography you can solve various cyber
security problems with it then we have
SQL that is structured query language
attackers use this language to damage
the stored data one such example is the
SQL injection attack hence having a good
understanding of SQL will be highly
beneficial
another Point we'd like to highlight is
to have knowledge of Assembly Language
this will help you become a cyber
security engineer assembly will help you
understand how malware functions and
thereby help you defend against it in
the cyber security domain you can't just
lock into a single language and hence it
is advised that you are acquainted with
a couple of them
you can also do a crash course with
these languages and learn them
hence determine the best programming
language for your cyber security role
and get familiar with the basics
moving on our fifth skill on the list is
cloud security
there is a growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals with Cloud
security skills in the coming years
companies are on the lookout for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public and hybrid Cloud
platforms such as Amazon web services
and Azure more organizations look to
Cloud infrastructure to store data and
run applications
this includes implementation of policies
and technologies that protect
cloud-based systems and devices
just like application development
security Cloud security also involves
building secure systems from the start
companies want professionals who can
manage the cloud security tools to
identify and prevent any Cloud breaches
people with experience and knowledge in
managing big platforms such as Microsoft
Azure AWS and the gcp are in high demand
now that we have seen the top 5 cyber
security skills let us go through a set
of additional skills that can help you
get into the cyber security field
remember that to become a successful
cyber security expert you must possess a
rich and diverse skill set
so in a list of additional skills first
we have risk analysis
identifying risks even before their
arrival is a great skill cyber Security
Professionals are required to identify
manage and mitigate risks
risk management and mitigation is a
skill set that is going to be highly in
demand in the coming years
next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized taxes here in-demand
skills are authentication authorization
malware analysis and data recovery
next on a list is security incident
handling and response
as a cyber security expert you must be
prepared to handle any forthcoming
threat of violating an organization
security policy by following an updated
incident response plan your team can
proactively protect your data and
minimize the damages
in security Incident Management you are
required to identify manage record and
analyze security threats in real time
a security incident can be an active
threat or a successful compromise of
data or an attempted intrusion it can
also be incidents like DDOS attacks
phishing apts ransomware and many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and even management Siem
tools and services
moving on we have security audit
security auditing is an internal check
that is carried out to find floors in
the organization's information system
you must be able to conduct a review of
the organization's adherence to
regulatory guidelines security audit and
compliance knowledge are very crucial as
any mystery of Regulatory Compliance
could lead to Hefty penalties
soon organizations will need people who
are more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations if you are good at
paperwork you can capitalize on this
skill companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to file and
which security protocols to use to
comply with the regulations
finally we have laws and regulations and
often Overlook cyber security aspect
there are several cyber security laws
and regulations and if you break these
laws intentionally or not it doesn't
matter as you will still be charged
these laws Define how you can use the
internet and it also defines how people
can be protected from becoming the
victims of cyber crimes knowing these
laws and regulations and following the
best practice will make you ethical at
your job and this will in turn be good
for your organization so those were our
list of additional skills apart from
these make sure you stay updated with
new hacks and learn new tools as cyber
security is ever evolving
another important skill apart from these
technical skills is your soft skills
having a set of good soft skills will
help you bag your dream job we have a
video on the top 5 soft skills that will
help you grow in your career do watch
that and incorporate those skills as
well we humans are highly tech savvy in
today's times with the extensive use of
the internet and modern Technologies
there is a massive challenge in
protecting all our Digital Data such as
net banking information account
credentials and medical reports to name
a few have you heard about the deadly
what a cry ransomware attack the attack
happened in May 2017 in Asia and then it
spread across the world within a day
more than 230 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries the
wannacry crypto worm encrypted the data
and locked the users out of their
systems for decryption of the data the
users were asked for a ransom of 300 to
600 in Bitcoin the users who use the
unsupported version of Microsoft Windows
and those who hadn't installed the
security update of April 2017 were
targeted in this attack the one at cry
attack took a toll on every sector
top-tier organizations like Hitachi
Nissan and FedEx had to put their
businesses on hold as their systems were
affected too now this is what you call a
Cyber attack to prevent such attacks
cyber security is implemented we can
Define cyber security as the practice of
protecting networks programs computer
systems and their components from
unauthorized digital attacks these
illegal attacks are often referred to as
hacking hacking refers to exploiting
weaknesses in a computer network to
obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems this
is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong there are hackers who work
with different motives let's have a look
at three different types of hackers
black hat hackers are individuals who
illegally hack into a system for a
monetary gain on the contrary we have
white hat hackers who exploit the
vulnerabilities in a system by hacking
into it with permission in order to
defend the organization this form of
hacking is absolutely legal and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers in addition to these
hackers we also have the gray hat
hackers as the name suggests the color
gray is a blend of both white and black
these hackers discover vulnerabilities
in a system and report it to the
system's owner which is a good act but
they do this without seeking the owner's
approval sometimes gray hat hackers also
ask for money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand more
about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking through an
interesting story Dan runs a Trading
Company he does online training with the
money his customers invest everything
was going well and Dan's business was
booming until a hacker decided to hack
the company's servers the hackers stole
the credentials of various trading
accounts he asked for a lump sum Ransom
in exchange for the stolen credentials
Dan took the Hacker's words lightly and
didn't pay the hacker as a result the
hacker withdrew money from various
customers accounts and Dan was liable to
pay back the customers
Dan lost a lot of money and also the
trust of his customers after this
incident Dan gave a lot of thought as to
what could have gone wrong with the
security infrastructure in his company
he wished there was someone from his
company who could have run a test attack
to see how vulnerable systems were
before the hacker penetrated into the
network
this was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
Network before an outsider does
to do this job he hired an ethical
hacker John
John was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in Dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future this in
turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation
so now you know hacking is not always
bad John in this scenario exposed the
vulnerabilities in the existing Network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking ethical hacking is distributed
into six different phases let us look at
these faces step by step with respect to
how John our ethical hacker will act
before launching an attack the first
step Jon takes is to gather all the
necessary information about the
organization's system that he intends to
attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like nmap
and hping for this purpose John then
tries to spot the vulnerabilities if any
in the Target system using tools like
nmap and Expos
this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them this step is known as gaining
access
after John makes his way through the
organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the Target
system
the Metasploit tool helps him with this
this phase is called maintaining access
John is a brilliant hacker hence he
tries his best not to leave any evidence
of his attack this is the fifth phase
clearing tracks we now have the last
phase that is reporting in this phase
John documents a summary of his entire
attack the vulnerabilities he spotted
the tools he used and the success rate
of the attack looking into the report
Dan is now able to take a call and see
how to protect his organization from any
external cyber attacks don't you all
think Jon is an asset to any
organization if you want to become an
ethical hacker like John then there are
a few skills that you need to acquire
first and foremost you need to have a
good knowledge of operating environments
such as Windows Linux Unix and Macintosh
you must have reasonably good knowledge
of programming languages such as HTML
PHP python SQL and JavaScript networking
is the base of ethical hacking hence you
should be good at it ethical hackers
should be well aware of security laws so
that they don't misuse their skills
finally you must have a global
certification on ethical hacking to
successfully bag a position of an
ethical hacker like John
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification ceh CompTIA pen
Test Plus and licensed penetration
tester certification to name a few
simply learn provides a cyber security
expert master's program that will equip
you with all the skills required by a
cyber security expert you could have a
look at it by clicking the link in the
description so let's start with what is
ethical hacking now plainly Define
ethical hacking is locating weaknesses
or vulnerabilities of computers and
information systems using the intent and
actions of a malicious hacker the major
differences here that we are hired to
discover those weaknesses in a legal and
ethical manner that means first and
foremost our intent should not be
malicious we do not wish any harm to the
organization and whatever we discover is
reported back and not misused once we
report back we will also be trying to
help them out to mitigate or remove
those weaknesses or vulnerabilities to
enhance the company security posture so
essentially would have the same training
or the same knowledge as that of a
malicious hacker except that the intent
is going to be different the intent is
going to help the organization and
Achieve security to protect themselves
against malicious hackers and the second
most important thing about ethical
hacking is that we are authorized to do
that activity I cannot in good faith
hack somebody and then tell them you
know what I just I just wanted to help
you out and here are your
vulnerabilities and uh this is the way
you can prevent them I first need the
authorization from the other party and
only then can I perform an ethical hack
so in this example hacker attacks an
individual with malicious intent and
makes misuse of whatever information
they have gotten they steal the data
they maybe fry the operating system
Hardware destroy it and thus they leave
the victim without a device with
authorization an ethical hacker can also
attack the same individual minus the
destruction of course and the intent is
good so they're willingly finding out
the vulnerabilities and helping the
victim plug them out so that they
wouldn't be a victim of a malicious
attack now here the first thing is a
authorization from the victim and the
second thing is the good intent where we
do not misuse those vulnerabilities and
we report them back to the victim or to
the client and help them patch those
vulnerabilities that's the main
difference between a white hat and a
black hat so Security Experts are
normally termed as white hat hackers
malicious hackers are termed as black
hats now the responsibilities of ethical
hacker are multi-fold first and foremost
you have to create scripts test for
vulnerabilities first have to identify
those in the first place so there's
vulnerability assessment identifying
those vulnerabilities and then you're
going to test them to see the validity
and the complexity of those
vulnerabilities so your one of your
responsibilities would be to develop
tools to increase security as well or to
configure Security in such a way that it
would be difficult to breach performing
risk assessment now what is the risk
risk is a threat that is posed to an
organization by a possibility of getting
hacked so let's say I as a ethical
hacker run vulnerability scanner on a
particular client I identify 10
different vulnerabilities within those
10 vulnerabilities I do a risk
assessment to identify which
vulnerability is critical would have the
most impact on the client and what would
be the repercussions if those
vulnerabilities actually get exploited
so I'm trying to find out in risk
assessment that if the client gets
hacked with the vulnerabilities
identified what is the loss they would
be facing once they get hacked and the
loss could not only be loss of data it
could be Financial losses it could be
loss of reputation penalties they have
to pay to the client for breaches or
penalties that they may have to pay for
pay the governments in case of breaches
that happen that couldn't be controlled
other responsibility of the ethical
hacker is to set up policies in such a
way that it becomes difficult for
hackers to get access to devices or to
protected data and finally frame the
staff for network security so we've got
a lot of employees in an organization we
need to train the staff of what is
allowed and what is not allowed how to
keep themselves secure so that they
don't get compromised thus becoming a
vulnerability themselves to the
organization the policies that we have
talked about are administrative policies
to govern the employees of the
organization for example password
policies most of the organizations will
have a tough password policy where they
say you have to create a password that
meets a certain level of complexity
before that can be accepted and till you
create that password you are not allowed
to log in or you're not allowed to
register so let's move on to understand
what is penetration testing now for
penetration testing there is a phase
called vulnerability assessment that
happens before this vulnerability
assessment is nothing about running a
scanning tool to identify a list of
potential flaws or vulnerabilities
within the organization once you have
identified the list of those
vulnerabilities you would then move on
to penetration test this is the part of
ethical hacking where it specifically
focuses on penetration only of the
information systems so you have
identified that flaw Maybe it could be a
database with a SQL injection or it
could be a buffer over Overland flaw or
it could be a simple password tracking
attempt your idea is to create those
tools create those attacks and try to
penetrate into those areas where
security is weak the essence of
penetration testing is to penetrate
Information Systems using various
attacks the attacks could be anything
like a phishing attack a password
cracking attack a denial of service
attack or any other vulnerabilities that
you have identified during the
vulnerability scan so what is Kali Linux
and why is it used Kali Linux is an
operating system often used by hackers
and ethical hackers both because of the
tool sets that the operating system
contains it is Operating System created
by professionals with a lot of embedded
tools it is a dbn based operating system
with Advanced penetration testing and
security auditing features there are
more than 600 plus or tools on that
operating system that can help you
leverage any of the attacks manage
fundamental attack sniffing password
cracking any of these attacks would be
possible with all the tools available
you just need to know how to utilize the
operating system and its tools contains
like I said 100 of hundreds of tools
that are used for various information
security tasks like computer forensics
reverse engineering information finding
even getting access to different
machines and then creating viruses worms
Trojans anything that you will 600 plus
tools in the Kali Linux operating system
there are periodic updates that are
given out to the operating system as
well it is open source that means it is
free to utilize you can even have the
source code you can modify it if you
want to test customizations available
for all the tools you can download third
party tools and install them if you want
there's a wide support for wireless
network cards multiple languages are
being supported at the time at the same
time as well and you can create a lot of
attacking scripts you can create
attacking tools and you can write your
own exploits as well on Kali Linux so
this all all in all helps you create a
very robust system where you can create
your own tags and then launch them
against unsuspecting victims now that is
illegal so as far ethical is concerned
once you have authorization you're going
to identify which tools to be utilize
you're going to get the appropriate
permissions and only then are you going
to attempt those attacks let's talk
about the phases of penetration testing
now there are five different phases the
first one is the reconnaissance phase
also known as the information gathering
phase this is the most important phase
for any hacker this is where the hacker
or the ethical hacker if you will will
gather as much information about the
target's victim or vice versa the victim
right so once you have that information
you would then be able to identify what
tool sets to include and how to attack
the victim for example you want to find
out the IP addresses the domains sub
domains the network architecture that is
being utilized you want to identify
operating systems that are being
utilized the network IP ranges that are
being utilized and so on so forth you
might want to identify employees within
an organization for social engineering
attacks in the future email addresses
telephone numbers anything and
everything that will help you validate
and give you information about the
target is something that you want to do
in the recognizance phase at this point
in time we are not going to question
whether whatever information we are
getting is useful or not only time will
tell depending on the various attacks
that we will be building up later on
this becomes your Baseline this becomes
your database with all the information
about the victim so that you can come
back from later stages back to the
reconnaissance phase to look at the
information that you have gathered and
then you can fine tune your attacks once
you have done that you are going to then
start the scanning phase based on the
information that you have gathered you
are going to identify live machines
within a network once you have
identified the live machines you'll scan
them for open ports protocols and
procedures any processes that are
running and then we were going to
identify vulnerabilities Within These
processors and within this open ports so
in the scanning phase why do we need to
find live machines because we want to
find out the machines that have booted
up have an operating system and are
running on the network if an OP machine
is not available on the network or is in
a shutdown mode that machine cannot be
hacked through a technical attack then
it would be a physical attack where you
physically go to the machine and then do
whatever you want to do with it for a
technical attack you will have to
identify the machines that have booted
up then you're going to scan the open
ports because that's going to be your
entry point and on the port would be a
service that is running so you scan the
service as well identify the version of
the service and then do a vulnerability
scan to identify if there any
vulnerabilities on those services that
are running and then based on all of
this information we are going to develop
our attacks as we go on so once we have
this we go on to the gaining access
phase where we are going to attack and
try to get access access to our victims
machines could be a social engineering
attack based on the information
gathering we have done in the technical
assessment and scanning phase if you
have identified a vulnerability you're
going to identify your relevant exploit
and then use that exploit to try to gain
access or we might just craft a Trojan
and try to execute that Trojan on the
victim's machine to check if we can get
access through that particular manner
once we have the access it could be even
a simple password cracking attack which
we have been able to accomplish and we
have cracked the password of the person
and now we have gained access to that
person's computer right but these
attacks would be temporary for example
we have cracked a password somebody
changed the password every 30 days after
that period our attack would be useless
if atrogen is executed we get a
connection to that machine for once but
then how do we get get a repeated
connection over and over again if you
want to reconnect to that machine so
that's where we come into the
maintaining access phase where we
install rootkits key loggers refers and
things like that where we could get a
backdoor entry to the victim's machine
if we have already been successfully
installed at Trojan we would want to add
the torsion to the startup menu so that
every time the operating system starts
the Trojan gets automatically executed
and thus we maintain the back door entry
to that victim's machine once we have
done all of this all these activities
are going to leave a trace in the
victim's machine so if we install a
Trojan a Trojan being an application
would create directories and files a
virus would be destructive in nature if
you are executing a script it will leave
some logs behind if we even log in
through the cracked password that we
have it will create a login entry and
for that particular timestamp along with
the IP address that we utilized in the
covering tracks we are essentially
trying to avoid detection by deleting
traces of our activity that means that
we need to identify where logs have been
stored we need to address those logs and
we need to delete them or modify them in
such a way that our activity T is not
traceable so these are the five main
phases of a penetration test gather as
much information as you can scan for
machines ports protocols and services
running on the victim's device try to
gain access by password cracking
extrusions exploits for the
vulnerabilities if any maintain that
access by installing further software
which will allow you to get backdoor
access to that particular system and
then try to cover your tracks by
deleting all traces of your activity
once successful the victim will have no
idea and you have a back door entry and
you can monitor the victim to the extent
that you want now in a ethical hackers
perspective this penetration test can be
done in multiple aspects so again
understand the fact that we are doing an
authorized activity we have identified
the tools that we have to use identified
the attacks we've got the appropriate
authorization and based on that
authorization we are conducting a
penetration test the penetration test
may be asked to be done in one of these
manners first is the Black Box test the
Black Box test is where no information
is given into the ethical hacker about
the ID infrastructure so they have no
idea what it is they start right from
the first phase of the information
gathering gather as much information
they can and based on the gathered
information they try to create and
launch attacks to see if they are going
to be successful now not only does it
test the knowledge of the penetration
tester it would also test the security
implementations that the organization
has done to see whether they can
identify the attack and prevent it in
the first place so this is the
simulation of a malicious hacker
scenario where a malicious hacker having
no idea about the organization first
tries to gather information and then
tries to attack that organization so no
source code knowledge no technological
knowledge nothing they're just going to
try to gather information scan those
devices and then try to gain access the
second test is a gray box test where
some information is given or some
knowledge of the ID infrastructure is
given think of it from a employee's
perspective a regular employee in an
organization who doesn't have extra
privileges like an administrator but
it's just a regular employee does that
means that they were limited access
within the organization based on which
they get some knowledge of the IIT
infrastructure so this is an attempt of
an Insider uh simulation attack where a
regular user may want to try to misuse
the access that they've been given and
then try to gather information or try to
gain access to other devices which they
are not authorized to the third test is
white box where there's full knowledge
of the ID infrastructure that has been
given so this is again a simulation of
an Insider attack a malicious Insider if
you will but at this point in time the
person has complete knowledge of the
infrastructure could be in an
administrative position and then they
are trying to leverage their access to
see if they can get information or they
can compromise any stock any of the data
so the three attacks would be the first
one black box where we are simulating
external threat a hacker sitting outside
the organization trying to gain access
the gray box is an Insider threat where
there is a regular employee who is
trying to get access to infrastructure
that they are not authorized choice for
and in the third order is a white box
audit where there's an administrator who
has all the leverage all the access and
the visibility within the infrastructure
and then they are trying to misuse their
access to see what else they can get
from whatever access has been authorized
to them now let's look at the areas of
penetration testing where all could we
do a penetration test thus compromising
the security of the application or of
the server or of the user so first and
foremost Network Services it finds
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in the
security of the network infrastructure
so for example we have switches routers
firewalls in the network all of these
are devices that need a configuration if
they have been not correctly configured
or if they have not been correctly
secured they would leave some
vulnerabilities behind if we as ethical
hackers are able to identify these flaws
these misconfigurations these
vulnerabilities we could then try to
exploit them and try to gain access to
the network and devices within that
Network by getting access to the network
in the first place then we have the web
applications web applications are
nothing but softwares that are developed
over or deployed over a web server and
are made available over the intranet or
the internet for example uh websites
that we visit or web applications like
Facebook if you will right so if these
applications have vulnerabilities within
them we then try to attack the web-based
applications and thus try to bypass
authentication or get access to database
or try to leak information through those
applications if not then we try to
attack the client side now web
application is at the server level and
it is hosted by the deployer so that's
at the server side the client side is
where we as users are using a computer
with a browser and trying to interact
with the web application now the browser
and the operating system that we are
utilizing would have its own
vulnerabilities thus identifying a
client-side vulnerability and then
exploiting it to either either hack the
client or then piggyback on the client's
connection and try to get access to the
server so either you could attack the
network the of application or the client
side itself or you could attack wireless
networks this test would examine all the
wireless devices which are used in a
corporation most of the wireless would
have laptops smartphones tablets tablets
all of those connected to them if you
are able to access any of these devices
to the wireless it would help you gain
access to other devices on the wireless
as well and in Social Engineering so
this is where you're trying to attack
humans you are tracking an employee of a
corporation to reveal some confidential
information knowingly or unknowingly by
tricking them with fake mails or fake
websites or malicious emails that you
have sent to them which they have failed
to recognize as malicious and they click
on it thus getting victimized social
engineering attacks are always
successful because of the gullibility of
humans empathy sympathy humans basically
have emotions emotions can be toyed with
and then taken advantage of if the
person is not careful enough for example
the most common social engineering
attack that we see is the Nigerian fraud
where we receive an email that someone
somewhere has died and has left a huge
estate behind a few hundred million
dollars and we have been identified as
the person through whom they want to
transfer the money to a foreign land to
save on taxes what are the chances of
that happening on a daily basis right
how many princes are there so that's
something that we do not verify it's
just the I guess the greed if you will
of striking it rich quickly that makes
us believe these kind of emails we have
also received emails of lottery tickets
that we have won over a period of time
without even having bought a lottery
ticket so if you haven't bought one what
did you win but we don't ask these
questions we just get excited about the
amount of money that we have won and
then we try to bet on our luck and try
to see if that email is going to
fructify or is it just under the scam so
social engineering attacks at time a
dozen these days and we need to be very
careful on what we trust on the internet
let's look at the penetration testing
tools there are hundreds of thousands of
tools out there most of these have been
concise and collected together and
hosted on a operating system known as
Kali Linux that we have talked about
earlier now the predecessor to Kali
Linux was backtrack backtrack is no
longer continued it has been
discontinued and Kali Linux has taken
the place of backtrack within which are
all the tools that you see on your
screen Metasploit is one of the most
favorite penetration testing tools of
hackers and ethical hackers there are a
lot of inbuilt exploits over there and
we'll be doing a demo at the end of the
session on this nmap is the information
gathering tool which will scan for live
devices scan for open ports protocols
and services beef would be an
application testing tool that would help
us find exploits within applications
nessus vulnerability scanner is a
network and a host based scanner that
would help you identify vulnerabilities
within such hosts Wireshark is a network
sniffer which allows you to capture
Network packets and and analyze them see
if there are there is any information
worth capturing within those packets SQL
map is a automated tool used for SQL
injection attacks so you don't even have
to craft your queries for SQL injection
it will be done by the SQL map tool you
just need to identify whatever is
possible through the queries that this
SQL is going to create and then based on
the activity that you've identified you
just need to redefine your search
parameters to get access to the database
we will be doing a demo on SQL map or
SQL map as well and then there is John
the Ripper John the Ripper is a tool
that is used for password cracking so
dictionary attacks Brute Force attacks
are done using John the Ripper what is a
dictionary attack a dictionary attack is
an attack where we create list of all
probable passwords store them in a txt
file and run that list against the
password tool to see if any of those
passwords are going to match a Brute
Force attack is trying the same attack
but with every permutation and
combination of the alphabet that we have
and we are going to try to figure out if
we are able to crack the password at all
so these are just some of the tools for
every tool there are another supporting
100 tools or more than that like for an
SS vulnerability scanner you'll have
college vulnerability scanner you have
uh ga5 Lan card and there are other lots
of other softwares out there but these
are some of the most commonly utilized
tools let's look at the Metasploit
attack Metasploit is a framework of
penetration testing that makes hacking
very simple you just need to know how to
utilize the tool you need to identify
the vulnerability associated with a
particular exploit and then run the
exploit on Metasploit we'll be demoing
this during the Practical so there are
active exploits and passive X coils in
active exploits exploits a specific
computer runs until execution and then
exits uses brute force and exits when an
error occurs in a passive exploit these
exploits wait for incoming requests and
exploit them as soon as they connect
they can also be used in conjunction
with emails and web browsers so in
passive exploits we create a payload we
like a reverse connect action payload we
send it to the victim once the victim
installs that software the machine will
then initiate a connection to us our
machine will be in a listen mode and
then we will once the software is
executed at the end we would then try to
connect and exploit that particular
vulnerability this is the uh practical
that we'll be doing on Metasploit so
let's move on with the demos and then
we'll see what we can discuss amongst
them all right let's have a look at some
of the demos that we had talked about in
the ethical hacking and penetration
testing module we are going to look at
three different demos the first one is
going to be a SQL injection attack that
we are going to perform on this tool
that we have the second one is a
password tracking attack on Windows 7
and a third one is uh Meetup reader
based or a metasploit-based shell shock
attack on a Linux based web server so
let's get cracking I've powered on this
virtual machine which is the ovas broken
web application it is a tool that is
provided for people who want to enhance
their skills and they can practice how
to do these attacks in a legal manner so
we are going to go to this site I'm just
going to open up my browser the IP
address is 71.132 and that's the ovas
broken web application that we want to
utilize we're going to head off to
mutility2 and we are going to look at a
SQL injection attack where we want to
bypass authentication now this takes us
to the login screen so we can just try
our luck here and see that the
authentication mechanism works the
account does not exist so the username
and password that we have supplied is
not the correct one so we want to ensure
that there's a SQL database and we can
try to attack it and see if we can
bypass the authentication now what we
want to do is we want to create a SQL
based malformed query that can give us a
different output so I'm just going to
type in a single quote over here and
type login and you can see that this is
now suddenly recognized as a operator
and there's an error that is given out
compared to the login that we tried
earlier when we used a proper text-based
login mechanism it gave us the account
does not exist but here the single code
gave us a error and it shows us how SQL
works this is the query that we had
created now in the trainings that you
have for ethical hacking there would be
explanations of what this queries are
all about how the syntax works here
we're just going to see if we can create
a malform query to log in as a user in
this case so what I'm going to do is
create the query over here I'm going to
give it a comparison so we're going to
give it R 1 equals one space hyphen
iPhone space and if you now click login
you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
SQL queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a Microsoft database an Oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
them at a demo this is how a SQL
injection attack works now let me log
out here similarly now we are in a login
page the same query work wonders where
it allowed us to bypass authentication
so it also depends on what kind of a
page I am and what query would be
accepted at this point in time so here
application understanding would also
come into the picture where uh which
function we are calling upon when we are
connected to a particular page now this
is a user lookup function right so again
here we try the same method test test
that's not going to work authentication
error bad user or password and if you
type in the same query over here single
quote or and give it a condition single
quote or one equals one high space
hyphenation space now here it is not
going to log Us in because this is not a
login page this is a user lookup form so
here it will instead give us a dump of
all the databases that it has so you can
see all the usernames and passwords
coming in that are stored in the user
lookup field so this is whether
understanding comes you know which query
to create at what page we are depending
upon the function that is being called
right so that's the SQL injection attack
that we wanted to look at let's move on
to password tracking now this is a
Windows 7 machine that we have I'm just
going to do a very basic password
tracking example we're just going to log
in now here the assumption is that we
are able to log in we have access to a
computer and we want to check out other
users who are using this computer and
see if we can find out their passwords
so that we can log in as a different
user steal data if required and we
wouldn't be to blame if there are any
logs that are created so here we've got
a tool called K N able that is installed
right here now I'm already an
administrator on this machine I am
checking out other administrators who
share the same privileges or any other
user who may be on this system whose
password I can crack and thus I would be
able to get access through their account
and then do any malicious activity right
so this allows me to go into a cracker
tool and it allows me to enumerate this
machine and identify all the users and
passwords that are there in this
particular machine right so I'm just
going to click on the plus sign and I'm
going to import hashes from a local
system so where are these files stored
where does Windows store its passwords
in what format are they stored and what
this tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as a
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from the local system click on
next it's going to enumerate that file
and it is going to give you a list of
all the users that are there so you can
see the users or hacker admin test the
one that we are logged in as and then
the user called virus as well and you
can see that this is the hash value of
the password that is being utilized now
there's a particular format for a hash
value for Windows and how it stores but
once we have these hash values let's say
if I want to crack this password there
are various attacks that we can do for
example a dictionary based attack or a
Brute Force attack let's try a Brute
Force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so we
are going to try to create an ntlm hash
attack and here we are going to use a
predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and lowercase A through Z uppercase A
through Z numeric 0 through 9 and all
the special characters let's say the
password is between 7 and 16 characters
and this is the character set that you
want to try the Brute Force attack on
what is a group Force attack it is an
attack where the computer is going to
try each and every permutation and
combination out of this character set
and try to figure out if the password is
going to be correct so if we click Start
it's going to start with a particular
characters and then it is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character and you can
see the time is going to be phenomenal
over here so it's not necessary that
this attack would be viable it will be
100 wasn't successful given the time
frame however the time frame is huge
enough for this attack to become a
little bit redundant there are other
attacks that we can do which can easily
identify this data for us as well but
that is something that we will look on
in future videos so that's how we can
get access to users and passwords there
are different mechanisms where let's say
we don't have login access then what are
we going to do how we can create a fake
user login or how we can remotely access
a machine and then try to get the same
access and that is what we are going to
try to do in the next demo on a Linux
machine so what we are doing in a Linux
machine could also be doable on the
Windows machine with a different exploit
so what I'm going to do is this is the
Linux web server that I have that I'm
going to power on I'm going to use a
Kali Linux machine to hack that device
and I'm going to just power off my
Windows 7 machine give it a minute till
it boots up now this is also a demo
machine that we have which has its own
pre-configured vulnerabilities so here
we've got something from the pen
tester's lab and has a shell shock
vulnerability implemented inside shell
shock vulnerability affects Linux Mac
and Unix based operating systems for a
particular version of The Bash shell
bash is the bone again shell which is
the command line interface in these
operating systems so what we are trying
to do here is we are going to use the
Kali Linux machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we are going to use Metasploit to attack
this machine now the first and foremost
thing is we want to identify the IP
address we have no idea what the IP
address is we are in the same subnet so
we are assuming that we are able to
connect to this machine so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up a
tool called zenmap I'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my IP address is and my appearance is
this with a subnet mask of
255255255.0 so I want to see if there
are any other machines that are live in
the same subnet and we are doing a pink
swipe over here to identify which
machines are live in a minute we'll get
all the IP addresses 71.1 to 133 254 and
128 we know that we are 128 at this
point in time uh 254 is the DHCP server
so we're assuming that 133 is the
machine that we want to look at and
let's then try to see if we can scan
that machine 133 and we're going to do
an Intel scan to find out which ports
are open what services are running over
there and if it is whether the pin test
machine that we were looking for you can
see of the start Port 22 and Port 80 and
somewhere here it's going to give us the
ports that are open and the details
about those ports and somewhere here it
will tell us that this is the pen tester
lab machine that we wanted which is
correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this what we
are going to do is I'm going to use
another GUI based tool called Sparta
which I can just find out from here
Sparta uses two tools in the background
nmap tool and a tool called nectar so
we're just going to start scanning 192
71.133 was the IP address add to scope
and over a period of time you can see
all of these will start populating with
information the VR that's the nickto
tool coming in scanning on Port 80 which
is uh which means that it's a web server
using HTTP it tells us it's an Apache HD
httpd 2.2.21 and gives us the 22 port
number as well if we head over to the
tab of nickto or let's look at the
screenshot first this is what the
website will be looking like and Necto
gives us the options over here it tells
us that there is a vulnerability over
here for shell shock and this is the
path where the vulnerability is going to
exist so what we are going to do we go
back to the command line sorry we open
up a new one minimize all these other
windows and we are going to open up
Metasploit Metasploit is a penetration
testing tool that is used by most
hackers and ethical hackers to test
applications and test existing exploits
and vulnerabilities so just give it a
minute till it starts you can see
they're already around 1700 exploits
right here we're going to see all those
exploits with these commands there we
are sorry for the typo and it will just
give us a list of all the exploits that
are stored in metaspoid in this version
so all of these are windows based if we
scroll up we'll be looking at other
vulnerabilities as well or exploits the
unique specs exploits Linux OS X
multi-exploits and we're looking for a
exploit for a multi-based Apache or HTTP
let's go up uh let's look at so this is
the one that we are looking for Apache
mod CGI bash environmental executable so
what we're going to do is we're just
going to copy it go back to the bottom
say use exploit and paste the one that
we wanted press enter say show options
so it will ask us to configure this I'm
just going to configure it based on the
knowledge that we have set our host
which is the remote host the victims
machine so we put in the IP address it
it asks us for the Target URI so that's
the path that we saw set Target URI to
CGI hyphen bin slash status enter now
with exploit we need to find a payload
that is going to give us the output that
we want so we say show payloads and it
will give us a list of all the
compatible payloads with this exploit
and we want to create a reverse TCP
connection which is this so we know it's
a Linux operating system we want this
payload to be set so set payload press
enter that's the payload coming in show
options now that we have set the payload
this is the options for the exploit and
now we want to set our options for the
preloads as well so we are creating a
reverse TCP connection which means we
are remotely executing code at the
victim side and making the victim
connect back to our machine which means
we need to set up a listener so I need
to put my IP address over here set
localhost or lhost
192.168 71.1 28 which was our IP address
show options again just to ensure
everything is fine which looks like it
is and we then type in the word exploit
so that it will start this attack I can
see that it has created a meter filter
session at the victim side and it has
opened up a session so if I do a PWD now
PWD is a Linux command for present
working directory and it will show us
that we'll connect it to where www CGI
hyphen win do an LS it will list all the
files that's the status file over there
do a CD backslash it will take us to the
root of this machine if you are an
aspiring cyber security professional
looking for online training and
certifications from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility
then search no more simply lens post
lecture program in cyber security from
MIT University in collaboration with EC
Council should be a right choice for
more details you can use the link
mentioned in the description box below
with the next generation of Internet
exchanges focused on maximum privacy and
security a variety of ways have been
enforced to maintain them as such
censorship has been shifted from the
streets to the digital domain it forces
the standard citizen to derive
alternative ways to maintain anonymity
major weapon in this battle for privacy
and security is the Tor Browser an
independent browser meant to browse the
internet file reeling information
through the Tor Network it serves as a
meaningful alternative to the standard
internet browsing habits to better
understand the purpose of this browser
and such we must learn about the work of
the Tor Network featuring its own
routing protocol the top browser is an
easy way to maintain anonymity while
browsing without emptying one's wallet
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today
we start at the explanation of what is
the Tor Network and its significance in
the working of the top browser
we take a look at the onion routing
protocol and how it transmits the data
from the client devices to the tort
directories in order to circumvent
government censorship
moving on we learn a few features of the
Tor Browser and the distinct advantages
the Tor Network provides next we learn
the difference between using a VPN and a
Tor to anonymize internet usage and
finally we have a live demonstration of
the Tor Browser anonymization features
in action
let's move on to learning about the Tor
Network
Tor short for the onion router it's an
open source privacy Network that permits
users to browse the web anonymously the
torque was initially developed and
solely used by the US Navy to protect
sensitive government Communications
before the network was made publicly
available
the digital era has disrupted the
traditional way of doing things in every
sector of the economy the rapid rise in
development and innovation of digital
products has given way to frequent data
breaches and cyber thefts in response
consumers are increasingly opting for
products that offer data privacy and
cyber security
Tor is one such underground Network that
was implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the Tor
Network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security concerns
the torn Network intercepts the traffic
from your browser and bounces a user's
request of a random number of other user
IP addresses then the data is passed to
the user requester Final Destination
these random users are volunteer devices
which are called as nodes or relays the
Tor Network disguises your identity by
encrypting the traffic and moving it
across different Tower relays within the
network
the Tor Network uses an onion routing
technique for transmitting data hence
the original name of onion router
to operate within the Tor Network a user
has to install the Tor Browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the
Tor Network it has its own feature set
which we will be covering over later in
this video
as we discussed already the data passing
through the Tor Network must follow a
unique protocol known as The Onion
routing protocol let us learn more about
its unique characteristics
in our normal Network usage the data is
transmitted directly
the sender has data packets to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind
however since the data can easily be
captured while being transmitted the
security of this exchange is not very
reliable moreover it becomes very easy
to trace the origin of such requests on
many occasions websites with
questionable and controversial content
are blocked from the ISP this is
possible since the ISP is able to detect
and spy on user information passing
through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the internet
however in the onion routing protocol
things take a longer route we have a
sender with the top browser installed on
the client system the network sends the
information to node one's IP address
which encrypts the information and
passes it on to node 2's address which
performs another encryption and passes
it on to node 3 address
this is the last address which is also
known as the exit node this last node
decrypts the encrypted data and finally
relays the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user
the Tor Network obfuscates user IP
addresses from unwanted surveillance by
keeping the user's requests untraceable
with multiple servers touching the data
it makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious attackers
now that we understand the way Tor works
let us learn more about the Tor Browser
the top browser was developed by a
non-profit organization as a part of the
Tor project in 2008 and its first public
release was announced
the Tor Browser is a browser forked from
the popular Firefox that anonymizes your
web traffic using the torn Network
if you are investigating a competitor
researching and opposing litigant in a
legal dispute or just think it's creepy
for your ISP or the government to know
what websites you visit the Tor Browser
might be the right solution
before the top browser were developed
using that Network to maintain anonymity
was a huge task for everyday consumers
starting from the setup to the usage the
entire process demanded a lot of
knowledge and practice the top browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay server Center and
guarantee the privacy of the data
Exchange
a major feature of the Tor Browser is
the ability to delete all browser
history cookies and tracking data the
moment it is closed every new launch of
the browser opens an empty slate having
a usage habits from being tracked and
singled out
a major feature that is the highlight of
the Tor Network is the availability of
onion links
only a small portion of the World Wide
Web is available to the general public
we have the Deep Web that contains links
that are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
Tor Browser gives you access to these
dot onion websites which are only
available within the torn Network
onion is a special use top level domain
which designates an anonymous onion
service which is also known as a hidden
service similar to The Links of the Deep
Web these onion links provide services
like online shopping cryptocurrency and
many other products not available in the
consumer Internet space
often being considered as a Haven for
illegal activities and sales on your
links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by authorities
browsing the web over Tor is slower than
the clear net due to the multiple layers
of encryption
some web services also blocked our users
Tor Browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced store as a
Cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving towards
anonymity properties
let us take a look at some of the
advantages of using the Tor Browser of a
standard web browsers
the highlight of using the Tor Browser
is to maintain anonymity over the
Internet the cause for such requests can
differ from person to person but all of
these concerns are answered by the tall
Network
routing the information via multiple
nodes and relay servers make it entirely
difficult for the ISP to keep a track of
usage data
the entire top project is designed to be
completely free and open source allowing
the code for the browser to be inspected
and audited by Third parties helps in
the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile devices
a number of websites are blocked by
governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via tor usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the Tor Browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive circumstances
many people believe that a VPN offers
the same benefits as the top browser
let's put both of them to the test and
see the differences between them
coming to the first point of difference
Tor is completely free and open source
all of the code for the browser and the
network can be audited and has been
cleared for security concerns when it
comes to VPN there are many different
brands which have open source clients
but the same cannot be said for their
counterparts some have partly open
source while some have completely locked
up their code so that they cannot be
stored in further
moving on Tor has multiple relay points
in his data transfer protocol between
the server and the receiver there are
three different IP nodes that number can
increase but it will always be more than
two
once the data is passed from the
surrender it goes through all of those
Julia points while in the case of a VPN
the connection is made from the client
device to the VPN server and then to the
requested destination there is no other
IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a
one-to-one between the client and a VPN
as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes through
similarly the multi-layer encryption of
Tor is consistent if you use Tor Browser
every single request passes so the same
layer of encryption and follows the same
routing protocol when the case of a VPN
different companies offer different
levels of encryption some have multi-hop
some prefer a single one-to-one
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more variable
finally the nodes and relays being used
in the Tor Network are volunteer there
is no company holding over them so
jurisdiction becomes relatively
straightforward for instance in the case
of vpns many such vpns are hosted by
adware companies or are being monitored
by Central governments to note the usage
information
now that we have a better understanding
of the Tor Browser and its routing let
us take a look at how the Tor Browser
can anonymize and protect our internet
usage
when opening up the Tor Browser for the
first time this is the page that you are
going to be welcomed with you have the
option of connecting to the Tor Network
before we start our browsing
so let's press connect
and we can see that it is connected
coming to the anonymization let's check
my current location on Google Chrome
currently is showing as Navi Mumbai in
Maharashtra
if we check the same link on the Tor
Browser we should get a different
address
now every link that we open in the Tor
Browser will be little delayed and the
speed will be hampered because of the
multiple layers of encryption like we
discussed now as you can see
it's showing a German IP and the state
of Bavaria
this is how the anonymization works
there is no VPN configured there is no
proxy attached it's straight up this out
of the box settings that come inbuilt
with the Tor Browser
similarly we have an option of cleaning
up the data let's say if you want to
refresh your location and you want to
use a different ID for the next browsing
session if we just restart it once
and you can have to check it again
we should be seeing a different country
this time
as you can see we have Netherlands right
now so this is how we can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that it
cannot be tracked when it browsing the
internet
like we discussed we have some onion
links that can only be used on the Tor
Network
as you can see these kind of lanes do
not open in the Google Chrome browser
but once we copy these over to the Tor
Browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the Tor
Network
this is kind of an alternative Wikipedia
website where we can find articles to
read and more information to learn
similarly we have another onion link
over here
which is once again available only for
the tall browser hmm
now these kind of delays are expected
but they are a valid compromise because
they maintain the anonymity that many
people desire
similarly we have found a hidden wallet
which is a cryptocurrency wallet which
is specifically for dark web members
this operates over the Tor Network and
this is used by mostly journalists and
people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing money
all of the transactions that occur over
the Tor Network are almost impossible to
track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available
Jude is waiting at the airport to hop on
her flight back home when she realizes
that she missed making an important Bank
payment
she connects her laptop to the public
Wi-Fi at the airport and goes ahead to
carry out the bank transaction
everything goes well and Jude completes
her transaction
after a couple of days she was wiped off
her feet when she learned that her bank
account was subjected to a Cyber attack
and a hefty amount was wiped from her
account
after getting in touch with the bank
Authority she learned that her account
was hacked at the airport
she didn't realize that the public Wi-Fi
she used might have caused her this
trouble
Jude wishes that Hatter bank transfer
escaped the Hacker's eyes she would not
have been a victim of a Cyber attack
officials advise her to use a VPN for
future transactions especially when
connecting to an open or public network
like most of us Jude had come across the
term VPN several times but didn't know
much about it and little did she think
that the repercussions of not using a
VPN would be this bad
let's understand how the hacker would
have exploited Jude's transaction in the
absence of a VPN
in this process Jude's computer first
connects to the internet service
provider ISP which provides access to
the internet
she sends her details to the bank's
server using her IP address Internet
Protocol address or IP address is a
unique address that recognizes a
particular device be it a laptop or a
smartphone on the internet
when these details pass through the
public network the hacker who passively
watches the network traffic intercepts
it this is a passive Cyber attack where
the hacker collects Jude's Bank details
without being detected more often or not
in such an attack payment information is
likely to be stolen the targeted data
here are the victim's username passwords
and other personal information
such an unsecured connection exposed
Jude's IP address and Bank details to
the hacker when it passed through the
public network
so would you have been able to secure
her transaction with the help of a VPN
well yes
picture Jude's Bank transaction to be
happening in a tunnel that is invisible
to the hacker in such a case the hacker
will not be able to spot a transaction
and that is precisely what a VPN does
a virtual private Network more often
known as bpn creates a secure tunnel
between your device and the internet
for using a VPN Jude's First Step would
be to install software-based technology
known as the VPN client on our laptop or
smartphone that would let her establish
a secure connection
the VPN client connects to the Wi-Fi and
then to the ISP
here the VPN client encrypts Jude's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure
next the VPN client establishes a VPN
tunnel within the public network that
connects to the VPN server the VPN
tunnel protects Jude's information from
being intercepted by the hacker
Jude's IP address and actual location
are changed at the VPN server to enable
a private and secure connection
finally the VPN server connects to
Jude's Bank server in the last step
where the encrypted message is decrypted
this way Jude's original IP address is
hidden by the VPN and the VPN tunnel
protects her data from being hacked this
explains how VPN makes your data
Anonymous and secure when it passes
through the public network
and the difference between a normal
connection and a VPN connection
after learning about this Jude was
certain that she should start using a
VPN to carry out her online transactions
in the future this is also applicable to
each one of us even if you work remotely
or connect to public Wi-Fi using a VPN
is the safest option
in addition to providing a secure
encrypted data transfer vpns are also
used to disguise your whereabouts and
give you access to Regional web content
VPN servers act as proxies on the
internet this way your actual location
cannot be established VPN enables you to
spoof your location and switch to a
server to another country and thereby
change your location
for example by doing so you can watch
any content on Netflix that might be
unavailable for your region
imagine our houses without a fence or
boundary wall
this would make our properly easy
accessible to trespassers and robbers
and place our homes at Great risk right
hence fencing our property helps
Safeguard it and keeps trespassers at
Bay
similarly imagine our computers and
networks without protection this would
increase the probability of hackers
infiltrating our Networks to overcome
this challenge just like how boundary
walls protect our houses a virtual wall
helps Safeguard and secure our devices
from Intruders and such a wall is known
as a firewall firewalls are security
devices that filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic within a private
Network
for example if you were to visit your
friend who lives in a gated community
you would First Take permission from the
security guard the security guard would
check with your friend if you should be
allowed to entry or not if all is well
your access is granted on the other hand
the security guard would not Grant
permission to a trespasser looking to
enter the same premises here the entry
access depends solely on your friend the
resident's discretion the role of the
security guard in this case is similar
to that of a firewall the firewall works
like a gatekeeper at your computer's
entry point which only welcomes incoming
traffic that it has been configured to
accept firewalls filter the network
traffic within your network and analyzes
which traffic should be allowed or
restricted based on a set of rules in
order to spot and prevent cyber attacks
your computer communicates with the
internet in the form of network packets
that hold details like the source
address destination address and
information these Network packets enter
your computer through ports a firewall
works on a set of rules based on the
details of these Network packets like
their Source address a destination
address content and port numbers only
trusted traffic sources or IP addresses
are allowed to enter your network when
you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers infiltrating your network this
is when a firewall comes to your Rescue
by acting as a barrier between your
computer and the internet the firewall
rejects the malicious data packet and
thus protects your network from hackers
on the other hand traffic from trusted
websites is allowed access to your
network
this way a firewall carries out quick
assessments to detect malware and other
suspicious activities thereby protecting
your network from being susceptible to a
Cyber attack
firewalls can either be Hardware or
software software firewalls are programs
installed on each computer this is also
called a host firewall meanwhile
Hardware firewalls are equipments that
are established between the Gateway and
your network Linksys routers are a good
example of a hardware firewall
besides this there are other types of
firewalls designed based on their
traffic filtering methods structure and
functionality the firewall that compares
each outgoing and incoming Network
packet to a set of established rules
such as the allowed IP addresses IP
protocols port number and other aspects
of the packet is known as a packet
filtering firewall if the incoming
Network traffic is not for the
predefined rules that traffic is blocked
a variant of the packet filtering
firewall is the stateful inspection
firewall these types of firewalls not
only examine each Network packet but
also checks whether or not that Network
packet is part of an established network
connection
such firewalls are also referred to as
Dynamic packet filtering firewalls our
next type of firewall is called a proxy
firewall this draws close comparison to
how you give proxy attendance for a
friend like how you take the authority
to represent your friend the proxy
firewall pretends to be you and
interacts with the internet
they come between you and the internet
and thereby prevents direct connections
this protects your device's identity and
keeps the network safe from potential
attacks only if the incoming data packet
contents are protected the proxy
firewall transfers it to you they are
also known as application Level Gateway
the firewall can spot malicious actions
and block your computer from receiving
data packets from harmful sources in
addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
institutions and offices to restrict
users access to certain websites or
applications it is used to avoid access
to unauthorized content the year was
1971 an engineer named Bob Thompson at
BBN an American research and development
company later acquired by Raytheon
created the world's first virus proof of
concept dubbed the creep although
credited and referenced by various
entities as the world's first computer
virus the creeper actually exhibited the
behavior of a war
I am the creeper and Catch Me If You Can
this is what the virus said and the
world was never the same with over 12
types of malwares and over 100 types of
viruses lurking around the network
channels of the internet waiting to curb
innocent users and exploit
vulnerabilities the 21st century saw a
tremendous growth in cyber crimes and so
did the need and demand for cyber
Security Experts hello everyone and
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this video we'll take a look at
malware's the bread and butter of
thousands of hackers globally and what
are its various types we'll dive deep
into understanding how each of these
malwares function and how they
differentiate from each other but before
that if you enjoy watching these videos
and find them attractive then subscribe
to our YouTube channel because we bring
the best videos for you daily also press
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply love as we know the demand
for cyber security personals is
skyrocketing so if you want to master
the field of cyber security then simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security in collaboration with MIT is
clearly the right choice for you this
postgraduate program in cyber security
is designed to equip you with the skills
required to become an expert in the
rapidly growing field of cyber security
this cyber security program aims to help
you stay ahead of the latest cyber
security Trends key features of this
program simply learns postgraduate
certificate master classes from MIT
faculty featuring modules from mitscc
and EC Council access to ceh kit 25 plus
Hands-On projects and many more this
cyber security certification program
begins with introductory level skills
and then progresses to Advanced cyber
security Technologies
this program covers all the essential
skills you will need to become an expert
in the field of cyber security cyber
security is one of the top concerns of
businesses today in an industry from
securing data to anticipating cyber
attacks and placing enterprise-wide
safeguards to prevent them employers
worldwide are increasingly looking for
qualified cyber Security Professionals
to join so what are you waiting for find
the course link mentioned in the
description box below and enroll today
so without any further delay let's jump
directly on to our topic for the day so
let's start with what is malware malware
is the short form for malicious software
and it's like a sneaky digital Intruder
that infiltrates your device without
permission it's created by cyber
criminals who want to disrupt damage or
gain unauthorized access to your
personal information financial data or
even control your device remotely
think of malware as a digital bully
that's up to no good
so let's understand how does a malware
work
Step 1 intrusion malware sneaks into
your device through various entry points
like malicious email attachments
infected websites software
vulnerabilities or even through
removable storage devices like USB
drives
Step 2 is execution once inside the
malware starts executing its malicious
code it may install additional files
modify system settings or create hidden
processes in the background to evade
detection
step 3 is persistence to maintain
control over your device malware often
tries to establish persistence it may
create registered entries modify startup
settings or hide in system folders
ensuring it launches every time you boot
up your device
next step is exploitation malware takes
advantage of vulnerabilities in your
operating system applications on network
to spread its reach it may exploit
security weaknesses to propagate across
networks in fact other devices are steel
sensitive information
the step 5 is malicious activities now
that the malware has settled in it
carries out its intended actions
depending on its type this could include
stealing personal information capturing
keystrokes encrypting files displaying
unwanted ads or even hijacking your
device for cyber criminals remote
control
the next step is concealment malware
often employs techniques to hide its
presence and avoid detection it may use
rootkit technology to hide its files and
processes employee anti-analysis
measures or encrypt its communication
with command and control servers to
evade security measures the last step is
damage or profit ultimately malware aims
to achieve its malicious objective it
may cause damage to your system
compromise your privacy steal financial
information or create opportunities for
cyber criminals to profit have you ever
wondered how it feels to be a cyber
security expert after gaining a
certification so let's take a minute to
hear it out from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
career after taking the cyber security
course hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years old
and last year IOP skill with simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
IIT sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my ciss and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course of course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors I worked with many companies
before the security analysts and the
architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with Infosys as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course but first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
now that we have a good idea of how does
a malware work let's understand the
different types of malware more than 12
types of malwares are present in the
world today and each of them is
threatening to different extent so let's
discuss some of the most common and
hazardous malwares the first is virus a
classic Troublemaker that attaches
itself to a program or file replicating
and spreading across your system it can
corrupt or destroy data and even render
your device useless
the second one is warm a sneaky creature
that replicates itself and spreads
across networks causing congestion and
slowing down systems it can also exploit
vulnerabilities to gain unauthorized
access
the next one is Trojan Horse inspired by
the ancient greektale this malware
disguises itself as a legitimate
software tricking you into installing it
once inside it opens a back door giving
cyber criminals remote control over your
device
the next is ransomware this villainous
malware holds your data hostage by
encrypting it the Cyber criminals then
demand a ransom to restore access
leaving you feel like a character in a
digital hostage situation next is
spyware a nosy little malware that
secretly monitors your activities
collecting sensitive informations like
password browsing habits and even
keystrokes talk about an invasion of
privacy
the next one is adware
an annoying Troublemaker that bombards
you with unwanted advertisements pop-ups
and redirects it's like a clingy digital
salesperson that never takes no foreign
answer
so those are some of the truly menacing
types of malware but knowledge is power
so how can we protect ourselves from
these digital villains
the first step is keep your software up
to date regularly update your operating
system antivirus software and
applications these updates often include
security pages to fix vulnerabilities
use strong and unique passwords avoid
using common or easy to guess passwords
opt for a combination of letters numbers
and symbols next is be cautious while
you are online avoid clicking on
suspicious links downloading files from
untrustworthy sources or opening email
attachments from unknown senders stay
vigilant next one is install reputable
antivirus software
invest in reliable antivirus software
that can detect and remove malwares last
is backup your data regularly backup
your important files and data to an
external hard drive or cloud storage
that way even if your device gets
infected you can restore your files
anytime
so I guess you guys must have got a good
idea about what is a malware and how to
stay safe from a malware now you may be
wondering what is SQL injection well let
us explain SQL injection is a serious
vulnerability affecting web applications
where attackers can execute unintended
code on a server by injecting malicious
SQL commands into a database query if
successful an attacker can gain
unauthorized access to sensitive data or
even modify it so if you are a web
developer this is something you must
take seriously but don't worry in this
video we will explain how SQL injection
works why it's so dangerous and how you
can protect your application from it so
be sure to watch until the end to learn
how to safeguard your apps from this
thread before we begin if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who only sits to switch
careers with cyber security while
learning from the experts then try
giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
that is in collaboration with the
modules from MIT Schwartzman College of
Engineering and the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will navigate you to the course page
where you can find a complete audio of
the program being offered and if these
are the types of videos you would like
to watch then hit the Subscribe button
like and press the Bell icon to never
miss on any update and here we go and
now we'll see the agenda for our
tutorial starting with we'll first see
what is SQL injection then we'll see how
does a SQL injection attack work then
we'll see what are types of SQL
injection tags and then we'll see the
detection and prevention of SQL
injection attacks then we'll see some
real life examples that happen with the
SQL injections and then we'll have an
overview of impact of SQL injection
attacks now we will start with what is
SQL injection SQL injection is a
technique used by attackers to
manipulate a web applications database
queries by injecting malicious SQL code
into input Fields attackers can execute
unauthorized commands and potentially
gain access to sensitive information SQL
injection attacks primarily Target web
applications that use SQL databases such
as MySQL Oracle or Microsoft SQL server
and now we will see how does a SQL
injection attack work so to understand
how a SQL injection attack Works let's
consider how a typical SQL query
functions queries are used to retrieve
or modify data from a database attackers
exploit vulnerable input Fields by
injecting malicious SQL code that alters
the intended behavior of the query and
attackers first study the targeted
database to understand its structure and
behavior then they craft a SQL query
that the server interprets as a
legitimate command for example or one
equal to 1 that is a queries input field
an attacker can bypass authentication
and gain access unauthorized access and
SQL injection and tags can also be used
to delete data manipulatory codes or
retrieve information from multiple
database tables using techniques like
error based injection Union based
attacks or inferential SQL injection now
we'll see an example to understand this
concept more so consider a website that
has search feature where users can
search for products by entering keywords
the website uses a SQL database to store
product information in a secure scenario
the website would take the user's input
sanitize it and construct a SQL query to
fetch the relevant products for example
the query might look like this that is
Select star from products where name
like and the entered keyword what they
want to search so this query retrieves
products whose names contain the entered
keyword however if the website is
vulnerable to SQL injection an attacker
can manipulate the input to execute
medicio SQL statements let's say the
attacker wants to retrieve all product
from the database regardless of the
entire keyword in the search field they
entered or 1 equal to 1 hyphen hyphen
the input manipulates the SQL query and
this query becomes this that is Select
star from products where name like
Ampersand and then or one equal to 1
hyphen hyphen percent in this case the
attacker uses the single code to close
the existing string followed by 4 1
equal to 1 hyphen hyphen to inject a new
condition that is always true the
semicolon is used to terminate the
previous statement and the double
hyphens are used to comment out the
remaining portion of the original query
as a result the modified query
effectively becomes that you can see on
the screen and the condition 1 equal to
1 is always true so the query retrieves
all products from the database
regardless of the keyword and this
example demonstrates how an attacker can
expert a vulnerable SQL injection point
to modify the C equal queries logic and
relative unintended data remember this
example is simplified for educational
purposes and real world SQL injection
attacks can be more sophisticated it's
crucial to secure web applications
against SQL injection vulnerabilities to
prevent unauthorized access and data
breaches now we'll see types of SQL
injection attacks so there are different
types of SQL injection attacks that
attackers can employ let's explore a few
of them the first we will explore is
invent SQL I I is injection here that is
in band SQL injection so this type
includes error based and Union based
attacks where attackers use the same
channel to launch Channel attack and
collect the results and the next is
inferential SQL injection that is also
known as blind SQL injection this type
involves sending data payloads to the
database server to observe its response
without directly seeing the results it
can be either Boolean based or time
based and the next is out of band SQL
injection in in cases where invent SQL
injection is not possible attackers
leverage other channels such as DNS or
HTTP request to retrieve data from the
database now we'll see detecting and
preventing SQL injection attacks so
detecting and preventing SQL injection
attacks is crucial to safeguarding web
applications here are some preventive
measures so the first measure is train
employees own preventive methods that is
educate your ID teams including
developers and system administrators on
SQL injection attack vectors and
prevention techniques next we could do
is Implement input validation and
parameterized queries validate and
filter user input using an allow list
approach and use parameterized queries
or prepaid statements to separate SQL
code from user input that will not allow
any malicious hacker to enter any SQL
code into the input method and the next
is regular security scans perform
regular security scans to identify and
address potential vulnerabilities in web
applications and the next is keep
software up to date that is ensure that
all software including databases and
programming languages are regularly
updated to include the latest security
patches and protections against SQL
injection and now we'll see some real
life examples of SQL injection attacks
so let's take a look at some real life
examples the first is Tesla
vulnerability in 2014 security
researchers discovered a SQL injection
vulnerability on Tesla's website which
allowed attackers to gain administrative
privileges and access user data this was
one of the SQL injection attacks and the
next was fortnite vulnerability in 2019
a SQL injection vulnerability was found
in fortnite that could have enabled
attackers to access user accounts the
vulnerability was promptly patched and
the nexos Cisco vulnerability in 2018 a
SQL injection wallet availability in
Cisco Prime license manager granted
attackers shell access to computers with
the install license management system
Cisco addressed the issue promptly and
last not the least we'll see the impact
of SQL injection attacks so the impact
of SQL injection attacks can be
devastating for businesses the first
could be the unauthorized access to
sensitive information and resources and
the next is potential data breaches and
exposure to confidential data and the
next is data manipulation or deletion
and the next is Network infiltration and
system compromise and the next is blows
of customer trust and decreased revenue
and the last is reputational damage and
long-term consequences for the business
and that wraps up our discussion on SQL
injection it's crucial for businesses
and developers to be aware of this
vulnerability and take necessary
precautions to prevent attacks stay
vigilant keep your software up to date
and educate yourself and your team on
best practices for web application
security Jane is relaxing at home when
she receives an email from a bank that
asks her to update her credit card pin
in the next 24 hours as a security
measure judging the severity of the
message Jane follows the link provided
in the email on delivering her current
credit card pin and the supposedly
updated one the website became
unresponsive which prompted her to try
sometime later however after a couple of
hours she noticed a significant purchase
from a random website on that same
credit card which she never authorized
frantically contacting the bank Jane
realized the original email was a
counterfeit or a fake message with a
malicious link that intailed credit card
fraud this is a classic example of a
phishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where fraudulent message is
sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted Source its basic
purpose is to trick the victim into
revealing sensitive information like
passwords and payment information it's
based on the word phishing which works
on the concept of baits if a supposed
victim catches the bait the attack can
go ahead which in our case makes Jane
the fish in the phishing emails the bait
if Jane never opened the malicious link
or was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively ineffective
but how does the hacker gain access to
these credentials the phishing attack
starts with a fraudulent message which
can be transmitted via email or chat
applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of phishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just provided often carried
out in campaigns or an identical fishing
mail sent to thousands of users the rate
of success is relatively low but never
zero between 2013 and 2015 corporate
giants like Facebook and Google were
tricked off of 100 million dollars due
to an extensive fishing campaign where a
known common associate was impersonated
by the hackers apart from credit access
some of these campaigns Target the
victim device and install malware when
clicked on the malicious links
which can later function as a botnet or
a target for ransomware attacks there is
no single formula for there are multiple
categories of phishing attacks the issue
with Jay or the hacker Stoler Bank
credentials falls under the umbrella of
deceptive fishing a general email is
sent out to thousands of users in this
category hoping some of them fall prey
to this scam
spear fishing on the other hand is a bit
customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a Netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the Netflix Team sends it
becomes pointless this is a potential
drawback of deceptive phishing
techniques on the other hand a simple
screenshot of a Spotify playlist being
shared on social media indicates a
probable point of entry the hacker can
send counterfeit messages to the Target
user while implying the source of such
messages being Spotify tricking them
into sharing private information
since the hacker already knows the
target use of Spotify the chances of
victims taking the bait increase
substantially
for more important targets like CEOs and
people with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10 full which can be
called a case of wailing the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their phishing attack often to
still industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price
apart from just emails farming focuses
on fake websites that resemble their
original counterparts as much as
possible a prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit webpage which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNS cache poisoning but
they are rarely carried out due to time
and resource constraints
now that we know how phishing attacks
work let's look at ways to prevent
ourselves from becoming victims while
the implications of a phishing attack
can be extreme protecting yourself
against these is relatively
straightforward Jane could have saved
herself from credit card fraud had she
checked the link in the email for
authenticity and that it redirected to a
secure website that runs on the https
protocol even suspicious messages
shouldn't be entertained one must also
refrain from entering private
information on random websites or pop-up
Windows irrespective of how legitimate
they see it is also recommended to use
secure anti-fishing browser extensions
like cloudfish to sniff out malicious
emails from legitimate ones the best way
to prevent phishing is browsing the
internet with care and being on alert
for malicious attempts at all times
if you are an inspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certifications from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility
then search no more simply lands
postgraduate program in cyber security
from MIT University in collaboration
with EC Council should be a right choice
for more details you can use the link
mentioned in the description box below
these DDOS attacks are getting more
extreme with hackers getting easy access
to botnet farms and compromised devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest DDOS attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020 lately
cyber criminals have been actively
seeking out new services and protocols
for amplifying these DDOS attacks active
involvement with hacked machines and
botnets allow further penetration into
the consumer space allowing much more
elaborate attack campaigns apart from
General users multinational corporations
have also had their fair share of
problems
GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DDOS
attack in 2018. widely suspected to be
conducted by Chinese authorities this
attack went on for about 20 minutes
after which the systems were brought
into a stable condition it was the
strongest leaders attack to date at the
time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
combat such attacks
even after years of experimentation DDOS
attacks are still at large and can
affect anyone in the consumer and
corporate space
hey everyone this is Baba from Simply
learn and welcome to this video on what
is Adidas attack let's learn more about
what is a DDOS attack
a distributed denial of service attack
or DDOS is when an attacker or attackers
attempt to make it impossible for a
service to be delivered this can be
achieved by thwarting access to
virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications
in a Dos attack it's one system that is
sending the malicious data or requests a
detours attack comes from multiple
systems
generally these attacks work by Drowning
a system with requests for data this
could be sending a web server so many
requests to server page that it crashes
under the demand or it could be a
database being hit with a higher volume
of queries the result is available
internet bandwidth CPU and RAM capacity
become overwhelmed
the impact could range from a minor
annoyance from disrupted services to
experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control center
the bots in the network attack a
particular Target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the DDOS
campaign
but how do these devices come under a
botnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how DDOS attack work
Adidas attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
botnet of devices
simply put a vast network of computers
are hacked via malware ransomware or
just simple social engineering
these devices become a part of the
botnet which can be triggered anytime to
start bombarding a system or a server on
the instruction of the hacker that
created the botnet
the devices in this networks are called
Bots or zombies
in the second phase a particular Target
is selected for the attack
when the hacker finds the right time to
attack all the zombies in the botnet
network send these requests the target
thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth
these can be simple ping requests or
complex attacks like SYM flooding and
UDP flooding the aim is to overwhelm
them with more traffic than the server
or the network can accommodate the goal
is to render the website or service
inoperable
there is a lot of wiggle room when it
comes to the type of DDOS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of DDOS
attacks
volume based attacks use massive amounts
of bogus traffic to overwhelm a resource
it can be a website or a server
they include icmp UDF and spoofed packet
flood attacks
the size of volume based attack is
measured in bits per second
these attacks focus on clogging all the
available bandwidth for the server
thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warranty reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate users
next we have the protocol level attacks
these attacks are meant to consume
essential resources of the target server
they exhaust the load balances and
firewalls which are meant to protect the
system against the DDOS attacks
these protocol attacks include syn
floods and Smurf DDOS among others and
the size is measured in packets per
second
for example in an SSL handshake server
replies to the Hello message sent by the
hacker which will be the client in this
case but since the IP is poofed and
leads nowhere the server gets stuck in
an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgment without any end in sight
finally we have the application Level
attacks application attacks are
conducted by flooding applications with
maliciously crafted requests the size of
application layer attacks is measured in
request per second
these are relatively sophisticated
attacks that Target the application and
operating system level vulnerabilities
they prevent the specific applications
from delivering necessary information to
users and Hawk the network bandwidth up
to the point of a system crash
examples of such an attack are HTTP
flooding and bgp hijacking a single
device can request data from a server
using HTTP post or get without any
issues
however when the requisite botnet is
instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and unusable
but what about the reasons for such an
attack there are multiple lines of
thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a DDOS attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them
the first option is to gain a
competitive advantage
many DDOS attacks are conducted by
hacking communities against rival groups
some organizations hire such communities
to stagger their Rivals resources at a
network level to gain an advantage in
the playing field
since being a victim of a detours attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some ground
secondly some hackers launch these DDOS
attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom
the resources are jammed and the only
way to clear the way is if the target
company agrees to pay a designated
amount of money to the hackers
even a few minutes of inactivity is
detrimental to a company's reputation in
the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index most of
the time a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a while
DDOS attacks have also found use in the
political segment certain activists tend
to use DDOS attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
forum
primarily political these attacks also
focus on online communities ethical
dilemmas or even protests against
corporations
let's take a look at a few ways that
companies and individuals can protect
themselves against DDOS attacks
the company can employ load balances and
firewalls to help protect the data from
such attacks load balances reroute the
traffic from one server to another in a
DDOS attack this reduces the single
point of failure and adds resiliency to
the server data
a firewall blocks unwanted traffic into
a system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect a DDOS attack in action
early detection of Adidas attack goes a
long way in recovering the data lost in
such an event
once you've detected the attack you will
have to find a way to respond for
example you will have to work on
dropping the malicious DDOS traffic
before it teaches your server so that it
doesn't throttle and exhaust your
bandwidth here's where you will filter
the traffic so that only legitimate
traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by a cluster
resources
the most important stage in DDOS
mitigation is where you will look for
patterns of readers attacks and use
those to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first step
Cloud providers like Amazon web services
and Microsoft Azure who offer high
levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DDOS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandwidth than most private
networks so it is likely to fail if
under the pressure of increased tdos
attacks
additionally reputable Cloud providers
offer Network redundancy duplicating
copies of your data systems and
equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a DDOS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a Beat
one can also increase the amount of
bandwidth available to a host server
being targeted since Cheetos attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection
this solution can prove expensive as a
lot of that bandwidth is going to go
unused most of the time
a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boosts
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates DDOS attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular cdns include
Akamai CDN cloudflare AWS cloudfront Etc
let's start with a demo regarding the
effects of DDOS attacks on a system
for a demo we have a single device that
will attack a Target making it a dose
attack of sorts
once a botnet is ready multiple devices
can do the same and eventually emulate a
DDOS attack
to do so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parrot security operating system
running
for a Target machine we will be running
another VMware instance of a standard
Linux distribution known as Linux light
in a Target device we can use Wireshark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly
this is Linux like which is a target
machine and this is parrot security
which is used by the hacker when trying
to launch a DDOS attack this is just one
of the distros that can be used
to launch the attack we must first find
the IP address of our Target
so to find the IP address we open the
terminal
we use the command ifconfig
and here we can find the IP address
now remember we're launching this attack
in VMware now the both the instances of
parrot security and Linux light are
being run on my local network so the
address that you can see here is
192.168.72.129 which is a private
address this IP cannot be accessed from
outside the network basically anyone who
is not connected to my Wi-Fi
when launching attacks with public
servers or public addresses it will have
a public IP address that does not belong
to the 192.168 subnet
once we have the IP address
we can use a tool called
hp3
hp3 is an open source packet generator
and analyzer for the TCP IP protocol
to check what are the effects of an
attack we will be using Wireshark
Wireshark is a network traffic analyzer
we can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the Linux light distro
is being displayed over here with the IP
address the source IP and the
destination IP as to where the request
is being transferred to
once we have the Dos attack launched you
can see the results coming over here
from The Source IP which will be parrot
security Now to launch the hping 3
command we need to give sudo access to
the console which is the root access
now we have the root access for the
console
the hp3 command will have a few
arguments to go with it which are as you
can see on the screen
minus s and a flood
a hyphen V
hyphen p18 and the IP address of the
target which is 192.168.72.129
in this command we have a few arguments
such as the minus s which specifies syn
packets like in an SSL handshake we have
the syn request that the client sends to
the server to initiate a connection
The Hyphen flood aims to ignore the
replies that the server will send back
to the client in response to the syn
packets here the parent security OS is
the client and Linux slide being the
server
minus v stands for verbosity as in where
we will see some output when the
requests are being sent
The Hyphen p80 stands for Port 80 which
you can replace the port number if we
want to attack a different port
and finally we have the IP address of
our Target
as of right now if we check Wireshark it
is relatively clear and there is no
indication of a DDOS attack incoming now
once we launch the attack over here
we can see the requests coming in from
this IP which is
192.168 72.128
till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux light
the requests keep on coming and we can
see the http
flooding has started in flood mode
after a few seconds of this attack
continuing
the server will start shutting down
now remember Linux light is a distro
that can focus on that serves as a
backend
now remember Linux light is a distro and
such Linux distros are served as backend
to many servers across the world for
example a few seconds have passed from
the attack
now the system has become completely
irresponsive this has happened due to
the huge number of requests that came
from Pilot security
you can see whatever I press nothing is
responded even the Wireshark has stopped
capturing new requests because the CPU
usage right now is completely 100 and at
this point of time anyone who is trying
to request some information from this
Linux distro or where this Linux distro
is being used as a backend for a server
or a database cannot access anything
else the system has completely stopped
responding and any request any
legitimate request from legitimate users
will be dropped
once you stop the attack over here it
takes a bit of time to settle down now
remember it's still out of control but
eventually the traffic dies down and the
system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into
that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
Adidas attack comes into play what we
did right now is a Dos attack as in a
single system is being used to penetrate
a Target server using a single request
now in a DDOS attack multiple systems
such as multiple para security instances
or multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and inoperable
as a final note we would like to remind
that this is for educational purposes
only and we do not endorse any attacks
on any proven domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack
a Brute Force are known as Brute Force
cracking is the Cyber attack equivalent
of trying every key on your keyring and
eventually finding the right one Force
attacks are simple and reliable there is
no prior knowledge needed about the
victim to start an attack most of the
systems falling prey to Brute Force
attacks are actually well secured
attackers let a computer do the work
that is trying different combinations of
usernames and passwords until the final
one that works
due to this repeated trial and error
format the strength of password matters
a great dream although with enough time
and resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is Baba from
Simply run and welcome to this video on
what is a Brute Force attack
let's begin with learning about Rufus
attacks in detail
a Brute Force attack also known as an
exhaustive search is a cryptographic
hack that relies on guessing possible
combinations of targeted password until
the current password is discovered
it can be used to break into online
accounts encrypted documents or even
Network peripheral devices
the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be time
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data obfuscation are
used and at times downright impossible
however if the password is weak it could
merely take seconds with hardly any
effort
dictionary attacks are an alternative to
Brute Force attacks where the attacker
already has a list of usernames and
passwords that need to be stretched
against the target it doesn't need to
create any other combinations on its own
dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general population
there is a three-step process when it
comes to brute forcing a system let's
learn about each of them in detail
in Step 1 we have to settle on a tool
that we are going to use for brute
forcing there are some popular names on
the market like hashcat
Hydra
and John the Ripper
while each of them has its own strength
and weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like Kali Linux and
parrot security
after deciding what tool to use we can
start generating combinations of
alphanumeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six digit password will create 900 000
passwords with only digits involved and
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially
the popular tools allow customizing this
process
let's say the hacker is aware of the
password being a specific eight digit
word containing only letters and symbols
this will substantially increase the
chances of being able to guess the right
password since we remove the time taken
to generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time
in the final step we run these
combinations against the file or service
that is being broken
we can try and break into a specific
encrypted document a social media
account or even devices at home that
connect to the internet let's say there
is a Wi-Fi router
the generated passwords are then fed
into the connection one after the other
it is a long and arduous process but the
work is left to the computer other than
someone manually clicking and checking
each of these passcodes
any password that doesn't unlock the
router is discarded and The Brute Force
tool simply moves on to the next one
this keeps going on until we find the
right combination which unlocks the
router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at their disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely due to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
use passwords
now that we have a fair idea about how
Brute Force Works let's see if we can
answer this question we learned about
how complex passwords are tougher to
crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comments
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next week
let's move on to the harmful effects of
getting a system compromised due to
Brute Force attacks
a hacked laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections it has been reported on
multiple occasions where compromised
Facebook accounts are sending malicious
links and attachments to people on their
friends list
one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to single device which belongs to
the hacker once brute forced A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via FTP Etc
personal information such as credit card
data usage habits private images and
videos are all stored in our systems be
it in plain format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other things
once a system is hacked it can also be
used as a mail server that distributes
spam across lists of victims since the
hack machines all have different IP
addresses and Mac addresses it becomes
challenging to trace the spam back to
the original hacker
with so many harmful implications
arising from a boot Force attack it's
imperative that the general public must
be protected against such let's learn
about some of the ways we can prevent
ourselves from becoming a victim of
Brute Force attacks
using passwords consisting of alphabets
letters and numbers have a much higher
chance of withstanding Brute Force
attacks thanks to the sheer number of
combinations they can produce
the longer the password the less likely
it is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them
having alphanumeric passwords also
allows the user to keep different
passwords for different websites this is
to ensure that if a single account or a
password is compromised due to a breach
or a hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the incident
two-factor authentication involves
receiving a one-time password on a
trusted device before a new login is
allowed this OTB can be obtained either
via email SMS or specific to fa
applications like authi and Aegis
email and SMS based otps are considered
relatively less secure nowadays due to
the ease with which SIM cards can be
duplicated and mailboxes can be hacked
applications that are specifically made
for 2fa Cores are much more reliable and
secure
captures are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website
since Brute Force tools are automated
forcing the hacker to solve captcha for
every iteration of a password manually
is very challenging the capture system
can filter out these automated Bots that
keep refreshing the page with different
credentials thereby reducing the chances
of Brute Force considerably
a definite rule that locks the account
being hacked for 30 minutes after a
specific number of attempts is a good
way to prevent Brute Force attempts many
websites lock account for 30 minutes
after three failed password attempts to
secure the account against any such
attack and an additional note some
websites also send an email instructing
the user that there have been three
insecure attempts to log into the
website
let's look at a demonstration of how
Brute Force attacks work in a real world
situation
the world has gone Wireless with Wi-Fi
taking the reins in every household it's
natural that the security will always be
up for debate
to further test the security index and
understand Brute Force attacks we will
attempt to break into the password of a
Wi-Fi router for that to happen we first
need to capture a handshake file which
is a connection file from the Wi-Fi
router to a connecting device like a
mobile or a laptop
the operating system used for this
process is parrot security a Linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
to start our demo we're going to use a
tool called air Garden which is made to
hack into wireless network specifically
at this point it's going to check for
all the necessary scripts that are
installed in the system
to crack into a Wi-Fi and to capture the
handshake file we're going to need an
external network card
the significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode
for now the wlx1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select
to be able to capture data over the air
we're going to need to put it in monitor
mode as you can see above it's written
it is in manage mode right now
so we're going to select option 2 which
is to put the interface in monitor mode
and its name is now wlan0 monitor
the monitor mode is necessary to capture
data over the air
that is the necessary Json why we need
an external card since a lot of inbuilt
cards that come with the laptops and the
systems they cannot have a monitor mode
installed
once we select the mode we can go into
the fifth which is the handshake tools
menu
in the first step we have to explore for
targets and it is written that monitor
mode is necessary to select a Target
so let's explore for targets
and press enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network jio 24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi's this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices
those channels features on one or two or
there are some many channels that the
networks can focus on
this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example
the station that you can see 5626 this
is supposed to be the MAC address of the
device that is connected to a router
this basis ID is supposed to be which
wi-fi it is connected to for example
5895 d8
is this one
which is the jio 24 router so we already
know which router has a device connected
to it and we can use our attack to
capture this handshake
now that we it has already run for one
minute now that we press Ctrl C
we will be asked to select a Target see
it has already selected the number five
which is the jio 24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake for
select Network 5
and we run a capture handshake
it says we have a valid WPA WPA2 Network
Target selected and that the script can
continue
now to capture the handshake we have a
couple of attacks a Dior air replay
attack what this attack does is kick the
clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the handshake
for our demo let's go with the second
option that is the dioc air replay
attack
select a timeout value let's say we give
it 60 Seconds
and we start the script
we can see it capturing data from the
jio 24 Network and here we go
we have the WPA handshake files
once the handshake file is captured you
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a peak MK
ID from the target network has
successfully been captured this is the
file that is already stored
the chart cap file for the path we can
let's say we can keep it in a desktop
okay we give the path
and the handshape file is generated
we can already see
a Target over here same jio 24 router
with the BSS ID
now if we return to its main menu
we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key
so let's go to the offline WPA WP to
decrypt menu
since you'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option 1
now to run the Brute Force tool we have
two options either we can go with the
air crack or we can go with the hashcad
let's go with lcac plus crunch which is
a Brute Force attack against a handshake
file we can go with option two
it can already detect the capture file
that we have generated
so we select yes
the bssid is the one which denotes the
jio 24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA to psk key
will always be more than 8 digits and
Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10. and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as 20.
the character set that we're going to
use for checking the password
will affect the time taken to Brute
Force for example if we already know
that or we have seen a user use the
password while connecting to the router
as something that has only numbers and
symbols then we can choose accordingly
let's say if we go with only uppercase
characters and numeric characters
go with option seven
and it's going to start decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this passphrase over here
the first five or six digits are a
it starts working its way from the end
from the last character it keeps trying
every single combination you can see the
last the fourth character from the right
side the D it will eventually turn to E
because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end
this will keep going on until all the
single characters are tested and every
single combination is tried out
since the handshake file is encrypted
using the security key that is the WPA
Tookie of the router whichever
passphrase is able to decrypt the
handshake key completely will be the key
of the Wi-Fi router this is the way we
can Brute Force into Wi-Fi routers
anywhere in the world cyber attacks are
frequently making headlines in today's
digital environment at any time everyone
who uses a computer could become a
victim of a Cyber attack
there are various thoughts of cyber
attacks ranging from phishing to
password attacks in this video we'll
look into one such attack that is known
as botnet but before we begin if you
love watching Tech videos subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon never
to miss an update to begin with let's
take a look at some of the famous potent
attacks
the first one is Mirai botnet which is a
malicious program designed to attack
vulnerable iot devices and infect them
to form a networker Bots
that on command perform basic and medium
level denial of service attacks then we
have the zoo's bot specifically designed
for attacking the system for Bank
related information and data now let's
see what exactly a botnet is
botnet refers to a network of hijacked
interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious quotes known as
malware
each of these infected devices are known
as Bots and a hijacked criminal known as
bot hoarder remotely controls them
the Bots are used to automate large
scale attacks including Data Theft
server failure malware propagation
and denial of service attacks
now that we know what exactly a button
it is let's dive deeper into learning
how botnet works
during the preparation of a bottleneck
Network the first step involves
preparing the botnet Army after that the
connection between the botnet Army and
the control server established and the
end the launching of the attack is done
by the bot hoarder let's understand
through our illustration
firstly we have a bot order that
initiates the attack
according to the control server commands
the devices that are infected with the
malware programs and begins to attack
the infected system let's see some
details regarding the preparation of the
botnet army
the first step is known as the prepping
the botnet army the first step is
creating a botnet is to infect as many
as connected devices as possible this
ensures that there are enough Bots to
carry out the attack
this way it creates Bots either by
exploiting the security gaps in the
software or websites or using phishing
attacks they are often deployed through
Trojan horses
for the next step we have establishing
the connection
once it hacks a device as per previous
step it infects it with a specific
malware that connects the device back to
the control button server a bot holder
uses command programming to drive the
bot's actions
and the last step is known as launching
the attack once infected a bot allows
access to admin level operation like
Gathering and stealing of data reading
and rewriting the system data monitoring
user activities performing the analogs
of its attacks including other cyber
crimes
now let's take a look at the important
architecture
the first type is known as client server
model the client server model is a
traditional model that operates with the
help of a command and control center
server and communication protocols like
IRC
when the bot order issues a command to
the server it is then relayed to the
clients to perform malicious actions
then we have peer-to-peer model
here controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the ports are topological
interconnected and acts as both CNC
servers that is the server and the
client today hackers adopt this approach
to avoid detection and single point
failure
in the end we will see some points on
some counter measure against botnet
attacks
the first step is to have updated
drivers and system updates after that we
should avoid clicking random pop-ups or
links that we often see on the internet
and lastly having certified antivirus
anti-spyware softwares and firewall
installed into a system will protect
against malware attack the internet is
an endless source of information and
data still in some cases we come across
some occurrences like cyber attacks
hacking 4 Century which may affect a
Time on the web
hi everyone and welcome to the simple
learn Channel today we will discuss a
topic that secretly records our input
data that is known as key loggers but
before we begin if you like watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update
to understand the key logging problem
better let's take a look at an example
this is June she works in a business
firm where she manages the company's
data regularly
this is Jacob from the information
Department who is here to inform her
about some of the security protocols
during the briefing she informed him
about some of the problems a system was
facing with which included slow reaction
speed and unusual internet activity
as Jacob heard about the problems with
the system he thinks of the possibility
what could be the reason behind these
problems a system was facing with
the conclusion that he came across was
the key logging issue
unknown to the problem her system was
facing with she asked him about some of
the details regarding it
for today's topic we learn what exactly
keyloggers are and how they affect our
system what are the harmful effects that
key logging can bring into the system to
begin with we learn what exactly the key
logging program is
as your name suggests keylogger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record keystrokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a log file then the same program
secretly sends these log files to its
origin
where they can be used for malicious
acts by the hacker
now that we know what the key logging
program is let's take a look how they
enter into the system
searching for a suitable driver for a
system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into a system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind a key logging issue entering into
the system
and lastly there are often cases where
different pop-ups that we often see on
social sites or different media sites
can lead to the installation of key
logging program into a system
now that we know how the problem gets
into the system let's take a look how to
identify whether the system is infected
by the key logging issue
the key logging issue can be identified
if there are often cases when a keyboard
lags behind the system
the data that we enter sometimes is
stuck in between when we type through
the input
then there are cases when the system
freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system
and lastly there are different cases
when we often see suspicious internet
activity on the system that we don't
know about this could lead to the
identification of a problem into the
system
now we'll take a look at different types
of key loggers that are present on the
net which can harm our system
differently
the first problem that keyloggers arouse
is API based the most common key login
case which uses apis to keep a log of
the type data and share it to its origin
for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and locks it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggests they are a best key
loggers that store the form data that is
if we often use web forms or different
kinds of forms to enter different data
they can be recorded into the system by
the program and send it to its origin
then we have kernel based key loggers
these key loggers are installed deeply
into the operating system where they can
hide from different antivirus if not
checked properly and they record the
data that we type on the keyboard and
send it to its origin
and lastly we have Hardware Key loggers
these key loggers are present directly
into the hardware that is they are
embedded into system where they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
now let's take a look how hackers
differentiate different type of recorded
data and exploit them
when hackers receive information about
the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related issues
then in case of company data that is
recorded by the key logging program can
also affect the economic value of the
company in the market which may lead to
the downfall of the company
also in some cases the key logging
program can also log data about military
Secrets which may include nuclear codes
or security protocols which are
necessary to maintain the security of a
country
now let's take a look whether mobile
devices get infected with the key
logging issue or not
in the case of hand devices infection of
keyloggers are low in comparison to the
computer systems as they use on-screen
keyboard or virtual keyboard
but in some cases we often see different
kinds of malicious programs getting
installed into the hand device if we
often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites
and also the device that is infected
with the key login issue or different
kind of malicious program can often lead
to the exploitation of data that
includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the system
now to prevent a system from getting
infected by the key locking program
let's take a look at different points
the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering of
malicious program into the system
then keeping system security protocols
regularly updated is also a good habit
and lastly using virtual keyboard to
input a sensitive data which may include
Bank details login details or different
passwords related different websites
now that we have some understanding
about the topic of keyloggers let's take
a look at the demo to further increase
the knowledge about the topic
for the first step we have to download
some of the important libraries that are
required into the system
which is
this Library
now we'll run it
the system says the library is already
installed into the system
now let's take a look what exactly
modules are required from the particular
Library
from this Library we will import
the keyboard module which will help us
to record the data that we type on the
keyboard
now from the same we'll also import
key module
and The Listener module
and also
the logging module which will help us to
record the data into a log file
for the next part
we'll write a piece of code that will
allow us to save the data that is
recorded by the program into our text
file that will be named as key
underscore log text file along with the
date and time stamp let's take a look
now
we'll provide it with the file name
that will be given as
key log dot txt file
and also so the part where the format of
the data is recorded
put the brackets over here to contain
the file name now we'll write the format
in which the data will be recorded into
the log file which will be given as
the format would be
the message and the timestamp which
would be given as
a long way the timestamp
even as percentage
and ending it with the bracket
now for the next step we will Design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a look
while press function
would be a function that will come into
play when the keyboard key has been
pressed
is
and
this would go for the
format that we designed
in the above line
and
logging
the Pressed key
info
a string file
to be recorded
into the log file
now
we'll design a function that is while
release
that will come into play
fin
the Escape key has been pressed that is
the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from running
and in the end
we require for the functioning of the
program to Loop these functions that is
while press and wildly leads to continue
its cycle
that will be going for
while
press
and
on
release will contain while released
function
as
listener
and now
this part
would join the different threads and
store them into the log file
now that we have completed the code for
the program let's run it
we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now
to verify the program let's open Notepad
and on the notepad
we'll write
hello world
which will be the basic whether the
program is working or not let's take a
look
and we will go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page
go to the bottom
over here we see the key log text that
is a text file that we created
let's open it
and over here we have the data that is
created
as we started with Note
then this is a Hello World part that we
created just now
which shows that the program we created
is working properly
now that we have reached the end of the
module let's take a look at the summary
firstly we learn what exactly key
loggers are
then we understood what different modes
are present how the system get infected
with the key logging problem then we
learned how to detect the problem into
our system then we learn what different
types of key loggers are present on the
net
we also understood how hackers use the
recorded data from the program and we
also learn whether mobile devices get
infected with the key logging problem or
not and lastly we understood what
different points can be taken to prevent
the entering of the key logging problem
into the system before we learn about
the Pegasus platform let us understand
what spyware is and it's working spyware
is a category of malware that can gather
information regarding a user or a device
straight from the host machine it is
mostly spread by malicious links via
email or chat applications when a link
with the malware is received clicking on
this link will activate the spyware
which allows the hacker to spy on all
our user information
with some spyware systems even clicking
on the link isn't necessary to trigger
the malicious payload
this can ultimately cause security
complications and further loss of
privacy
one such spyware system that is making
the rounds in the tech industry today is
Pegasus the Pegasus is a spyware system
developed by an Israeli company known as
the NSO group it runs on mainly mobile
devices spanning across the major
operating systems like the Apple's IOS
on iPhone and the standard Android
versions this is not a newly developed
platform since Pegasus has existed since
as early as 2016. a highly intricate
spyware program that can track user
location read text messages scan through
mobile files access device camera and
microphone to record voice and video
Pegasus has all the tools necessary to
enforce surveillance for any clan that
wishes to buy its services initially the
NSO group had designed the software to
be used against terrorist factions of
the world with more and more encrypted
communication channels coming to the
Forefront Pegasus was designed to
maintain control over the data
transmission that can be a threat to
National Security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had complete control over who
how and up to what level they can put
surveillance limits on
eventually the primary clients became
Sovereign Nations spying on Public
Information that is supposed to stay
private became really easy with this
service
multiple devices can be affected with
the same spyware system to create a
network information this network keeps
feeding data to the host to understand
how a network can be created let's know
how a mobile device can be affected by
Pegasus
we all communicate with friends and
family over instant messaging
applications and email in some instances
if you check your inbox on a regular
basis you must have noticed that we
received some spam emails that the mail
providers like Gmail and Yahoo can just
filter into the spam folder some of
these messages bypass this filter and
make their way into a person's inbox
they look like generic emails which are
supposed to be safe the Pegasus spyware
targets such occurrences bypassing
malicious messages and links which
install the necessary Spy software on
the user's mobile device be it Android
or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS text WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threema once the malicious
links are clicked a spyware package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after the spyware is successfully
installed the perpetrator who sent the
payload to the victim can monitor
everything the user does
Pegasus can collect private emails
passwords images videos and every other
piece of information that passes through
the device Network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
by the primary spying organization can
monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex spyware software like
Pegasus can access the roots files on
our mobiles these root files hold
information that is crucial to the
working of the Android and iOS operating
systems leaking such private information
is a massive blow to the security and
the privacy of an individual
the information that may seem trivial
like the name of your Wi-Fi connection
or the last time you ordered an item
from Amazon are indeed all valuable
information this exploitation is
primarily possible due to the zero day
vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do
however many such critical bugs make
their way onto the dark web where
hackers can use them to create exploits
these exploits are then sent to innocent
users with a link or a message like we
had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with all the security patches
installed but some bugs are not reported
to the developers or just cannot be
fixed without breaking some core
functionality
these become the Gateway for spyware to
enter into the system
you can never be 100 safe but you sure
can give it all in protecting yourself
the one thing where Pegasus stands out
is that zero click action feature
usually in spam emails the malicious
code is activated when the user clicks
the malware link a user doesn't need to
click the link in the new version of the
Pegasus and a few other spyware programs
once the message arrives in the inbox of
WhatsApp Gmail or any other chat
applications the spyware gets activated
and everything can be recorded and sent
back to the central server the primary
issue with being affected by spyware as
a victim is detection
unlike crypto Miners and Trojans spying
Services usually do not demand many
system resources which makes them tough
to detect after they have been activated
since many devices slow down after a
couple of years any kind of Performance
Set due to such spyware is often
attributed to poor software longevity by
the users they do not check meticulously
for any other causes that is causing the
Slowdown
when left unchecked these devices can
capture voice and video from the mobile
sensors while keeping the owner in the
dark let's take a moment to check if we
are well aware of the causes of such
attacks how do users fall prey to such
spyware programs a by installing
untested software B by clicking on the
third party links from email and
messages
see by not keeping the apps and phones
updated or deep all of the above let us
know your answers in the comment section
below and we will revive the correct
answer next week but what about the
unaffected devices the vulnerable ones
while we cannot be certain of our
security there are a few things we can
do to boost our device be it against
Pegasus or the next big spyware on the
market
let's say we are safe now and we have
the time to take the necessary steps to
prevent a spyware attack what are the
things we can go for
a primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated with the latest security patches
the vulnerabilities that the exploits
Target are often discovered by
developers from Google and apple which
send the security patches quickly
this can be done for individual apps as
well so keeping them updated is of
utmost importance
while the most secure devices have
fallen prey to Pegasus as well a
security patch from developers may help
in minimizing the damage at a later
stage or maybe negate the entire spyware
platform altogether another big factor
is the spread of malware is the trend of
side loading Android applications using
dot APK files downloading such apps from
a third party website have no security
checks involved and are mostly
responsible for adware and spyware
Innovations on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into a
device you should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains
spiver is a controversial segment in
governance while the ramifications are
pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false veil of democracy
altogether
even if our daily life is rather
simplistic we must understand that
privacy is not about what we have to
hide instead it portrays the things we
have to protect it stands for everything
we have to share with the outside world
both rhetorically and literally hey
everyone
today we look at the hack which took the
World by storm and affected multiple
governments and corporations the
solarwinds attack
the global statistics indicate that
upward of 18 000 customers have been
affected potentially needing billions to
recover the losses incurred before we
have a look at this hack Make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
notification Bell to never miss an
update from simpler
the date is December 8 2020. FireEye a
global leader in companies specializing
in cyber security released a blog post
that got the attention of the entire IIT
Community a software known as Orion
which was developed by solarwinds
Incorporated had become a victim of a
remote access Trojan or a rat the breach
was estimated to be running since the
spring of 2020 and when virtually
unnoticed for months the reveals sent
the developers of the Orion software
into a frenzy as they quickly released a
couple of hot fixes for their platform
in order to mitigate this threat and
prevent further damage but how did this
come into existence
we first need to understand the platform
which was responsible for this breach
solo wins a software company based in
Texas United States had developed a
management platform known as Orion
catering to corporations and governments
worldwide Orion was responsible for the
monitoring and management of ID
Administration this included managing
the client's servers virtualization
components and even the organization's
Network infrastructure that bought the
platform
solarwinds claims they have more than
300 000 clients including U.S government
agencies and several Fortune 500
companies this entire chain can be
classified as a supply chain attack in
this variant of cyber crime the hackers
Target relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferability
services rendered by a third party since
there is no direct jurisdiction over it
in this case the Orion platform was the
primary target the culprit however was
software updates the update server for
solarwinds Orion had a malicious version
attached with malware or a Trojan to be
precise this was made possible since the
code repository that handled the
software updates was breached once the
update server repository was compromised
the source code of the applications
became open to modification and
malicious code found its way onto the
software the remote access Trojan was
attached to a potential update nicknamed
the Sunburst update this update gave
hackers backdoor access to any client
that uses the correct version on its
release many clients believe the update
to be legitimate since it came from the
right source and they had no reason to
believe otherwise
American government agencies were
supposedly hit the hardest as the list
of victims included the U.S departments
of Homeland Security treasury and health
several private companies like Cisco
Nvidia and Intel were compromised
according to a list published by the
cyber security firm trusec
most of the companies had issues quick
updates to fix this vulnerabilities
introduced by the software while the
actual perpetrators have never been
found it is believed that this was an
act of cross-border corporate Espionage
conducted by state-sponsored hackers
either from Russia or China
before we move forward let's take a
recap of the things we learned
category of malware was responsible for
the solarwinds hack was it one a virus a
remote access Trojan a spyware or a worm
let us know your answers in the comment
section right away and we will reveal
the correct answer in a week coming to
possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach
there are a couple of things that we as
consumers must always tend to when
working our way through the World Wide
Web
using a password manager is highly
recommended which can generate secure
alphanumeric passwords we must also use
different passwords for different
accounts thereby reducing the chances of
a single point of failure should one of
those accounts get breached usage of
two-factor authentication applications
is also encouraged since it acts as a
safety net if hackers directly get a
hold of our credentials
clicking on unknown links transmitted
via emails is also a strict no as is
installing applications from unverified
sources the solarwinds hack is estimated
to cost the parent company in nearly 18
million dollars as reparations making it
one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history
as recently as of July 2021 the hackers
access some U.S attorneys Microsoft 365
email accounts as part of the attack
criminal organizations like the FBI and
CIA are determined to figure out the
culprits responsible for this debacle
however the intricacy and the full
extent of the breach makes it a way more
complicated job than it looks on paper
the day is 26 February 2022.
the world is hit with breaking news that
Russian State tv channels have been
hacked by Anonymous a hacktivist
Collective and movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple Cyber Wars
in the past decade
this was in response to the Russian
aggression on Ukrainian territory in the
hopes of annexation
Anonymous hacked the Russian State TV
networks to combat propaganda in Russia
and highlight the damage to life meted
out by the Kremlin in Ukraine they also
hacked 120 000 Russian troops personal
information and the Russian Central Bank
stealing 35 000 files this served as a
clear indicator of how cyber War can
change the momentum in battle something
which people had never seen so closely
so what is cyber War
a digital assault or series of strikes
or hacks against a country is sometimes
referred to as a cyber War it has the
ability to cause havoc on government and
civilian infrastructure as well as
disrupt essential systems causing State
harm and even debt in this day and age
the internet plays a bigger role than
just watching videos and learning
content it's where you have your
personal data and carry Financial
transactions so rather than resorting to
physical violence Cyber Wars become the
new means to cause Havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet
in most circumstances cyber warfare
involves the nation's State attacking
another
in certain cases the assaults are
carried out by terrorist organizations
or non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's aim in June 2021 Chinese
hackers targeted organizations like
Verizon to secure remote access to their
Networks stuxnet was a computer worm
designed to attack Iran's nuclear
facilities but evolved and expanded to
many other industrial and energy
producing sites in 2010.
since the definition of cyber war is so
vague applying rules and sanctions based
on digital assault is even tougher
making the field of cyber warfare a
lawless Lane not bound by any rules or
policies there are multiple ways in
which these attacks can be carried out a
major category of Cyber attack is
espionage
Espionage entails monitoring other
countries to steal critical secrets this
might include compromising vulnerable
computer systems with botnets or spear
phishing attempts before extracting
sensitive data in cyber warfare
the next weapon in cyber war is sabotage
government agencies must identify
sensitive data and its dangers if it is
exploited Insider threats such as
disgruntled or irresponsible Personnel
or government staffed with ties to the
attacking country can be used by hostile
countries or terrorists to steal or
destroy information
by overwhelming a website with bogus
requests and forcing it to handle them
denial of service attacks prohibit real
users from accessing it attacking
parties may use this form of assault to
disrupt key operations and systems and
prevent citizens military and security
officials and research organizations
from accessing sensitive websites but
what benefits does Cyber War offer in
contrast to traditional physical Warfare
the most important Advantage is the
ability to conduct attacks from anywhere
Global without having to travel
thousands of miles as long as the
attacker and Target are connected to the
internet organizing and launching Cyber
Wars is relatively less tedious Than
Physical Warfare
people living in or battling for a
country are subjected to propaganda
attacks in an attempt to manipulate
their emotions and thoughts
digital infrastructure is highly crucial
in today's modern world
starting from communication channels to
Secure Storage servers Rippling a
country's footprint and control on the
Internet is very damaging
but what are some of the ways we as
Citizens protect ourselves in the case
of a cyber war in the unfortunate event
that your country is involved in Warfare
be sure to fact check every piece of
information and follow only trusted
sources in that frame of time even
conversations online should be limited
to a need to know basis considering
propaganda campaigns have the power to
influence the tide of War drastically
it is highly crucial to follow basic
security guidelines to secure our
devices like regularly updating our
operating systems occasionally running
full system antivirus scans Etc
if your country or organization is being
attacked having devices segregated in a
network goes a long way in bolstering
security
try to avoid sharing a lot of personal
data online
in this era of Instagram and Facebook
divulging private information can be
detrimental to keeping a secure firewall
for your data the more information an
attacker has access to the higher his
chances of being able to devise a plan
to infiltrate defenses
if you're an inspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certifications from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility
then search no more simply lands
postgraduate program in cyber security
from MIT University in collaboration
with EC Council should be a right choice
for more details you can use the link
mentioned in the description box below
we bring you the top 10 computer hacks
of all time but before we begin if
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the Subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting Tech videos every
day let's see what we have at number 10.
from April 27 2007 Estonia the European
country faced a series of cyber attacks
that lasted for weeks this happened when
the Estonian government decided to move
the bronze soldier from Thailand Center
to a less prominent military cemetery
located on the city's outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down Estonian Banks online services
media Outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnet sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated Online
requests according to researchers the
public faced DDOS attacks there were
conflicts to edit the English language
version of The Bronze soldiers Wikipedia
page as well although there is no
confirmation Russia is believed to be
behind these cyber attacks that largely
crippled the Estonian Society let's now
move on to the next attack on December
23 2015 several parts of Ukraine
witnessed a power outage and this was
not a typical blackout it was indeed the
result of a Cyber attack
Information Systems of three energy
distribution companies in Ukraine were
compromised it is the first known
Victorious Cyber attack on a par grid it
is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were Switched Off and
about 230 000 people were left in the
dark for about one to six hours U.S
investigators believed that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a Cyber attack cost a
21-day shutdown of NASA computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
Jonathan James he first penetrated U.S
Department of Defense divisions
computers and installed a back door on
its servers
this allowed him to intercept more than
a thousand government emails including
the ones containing usernames and
passwords this helped James steal a
piece of NASA software and crack the
NASA computers that support the
International Space Station which caused
a space exploration agency's forty one
thousand dollars assistance were shut
down for three weeks
he was the first person to carry out a
computer hack against the American space
agency let's now move on to the next
attack in late November 2014 there was a
leak of confidential data from the film
studio of Sony Pictures
information about Sony Pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased Sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked
this Cyber attack was carried out by a
hacker grouped named Guardians Of Peace
so what did the hackers want well they
demanded that Sony withdraw its then
upcoming movie the interview this movie
was a comedy storyline to assassinate
the North Korean leader Kim Jong-un Sony
then decided to cancel the film's
theatrical release due to the threats at
Cinema screening the movie it is indeed
hard to trace the roots of a Cyber
attack in this case after evaluation the
U.S intelligence officials arrived at
the theory that the attack was in a way
related to the government of North Korea
however North Korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six
in December 2006 TJX the U.S retailer
company identified that 45.6 million
debit and credit card details were
stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data
as a result banks in the affected
regions had to reissue and block
thousands of payment cards a group of
hackers did this Albert Gonzalez being
The Mastermind the group was from Miami
the place where the TJX Heist was
believed to have originated reports said
that the TJX data breach occurred
because of weak web encryption at two of
its martial stores in Miami next moving
on to our top five let us see what we
have at number five the year 2010
witnessed the discovery of the deadly
computer worm stuxnet this malware's
motive was unlike any other usual cyber
attacks it aimed at destructing the
equipment the computers controlled
stuxnet came with the deadly purpose of
damaging Iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 Industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in Iran
stuxnet initially spread via Microsoft
Windows and targeted Siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
It is believed to have been silently
sabotaging Iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuges of the Iranian reactors this
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by the US and the Israeli intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same moving on to number four in
the year 2014 Home Depot was the victim
of one of the deadliest cyber attacks 56
million payment cards were compromised
along with 53 million customer email
addresses stolen
this security breach happened from April
to September 2014. criminals were
believed to have used a third-party
vendors username and password to enter
the perimeter of Home Depot's Network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom-built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the U.S and
Canada
moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the PlayStation
gaming system is one of Sony's most
popular products unfortunately in April
2011 Sony Executives witnessed abnormal
activity on the PlayStation Network this
resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million PlayStation
users accounts and prevented users of
PlayStation 3 and PlayStation Portable
consoles from accessing this service
this forced Sony to turn off the
PlayStation Network on April 20th on May
4th Sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days Sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage in the end
Sony is believed to have invested
approximately 170 million dollars to
improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected let's now move on
to the next attack at number two in May
2017 one of the most dangerous cyber
attacks took place
it was known as the Warner cry
ransomware attack caused by the wannacry
crypto worm the victims were the users
that use the unsupported version of
Microsoft Windows and those who hadn't
installed the new security update
this did not take place through fishing
like other attacks but through an
exposed vulnerable SMB port
the attack originated in Asia and then
eventually spread across the globe in a
day more than 200 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
the wannacry cry crypto worm locked the
users out of the targeted systems and
encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 dollars
which had to be paid via Bitcoin in
exchange for their data this attack took
a toll on both private and government
organizations it resulted in Damages
from hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars in a matter of few days the
emergency patches released by Microsoft
halted the attack also the discovery of
a kill switch prevented the infected
computers from spreading the crypto worm
Security Experts in a few countries
believed that North Korea was behind
this attack and finally let's see what
we have at number one more than two
decades ago in March 1999 the Melissa
virus a mass mailing macro virus was
released it targeted Microsoft Word and
outlook-based systems and created
considerable Network traffic Melissa
virus infected computers via emails the
email would look like an important
message well yes it was fake if the
recipient opens the attachments in the
mail and downwards the document and then
opens it with Microsoft Word a virus was
released on their computers
this would then Mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victim's contact
list and then disable multiple Safeguard
features on Microsoft Word and Microsoft
Outlook this began spreading like a
wildfire across the internet David L
Smith released the virus the virus cost
nearly 80 million worth of Damages it
did not steal data or money however it
cost a Havoc almost 1 million email
accounts were disrupted worldwide
agencies were overloaded and some had to
be shut down entirely and internet
traffic in some locations were slowed
down security was traditionally
considered an afterthought in software
development it is becoming an
increasingly important concern for all
aspects of app development from design
to deployment and Beyond
the number of programs produced
distributed deployed and patched across
Network continually increases as a
result application security features
must deal with a wide range of risks
let's take an example
a malicious script may be mirrored on
the victim's web browser or kept in a
database and run whenever the user
contacts the proper function depending
on the kind of attack in question here
this allows malicious code to be entered
in the case of an output the major cause
of this attack is faulty user input
validation which allows malicious input
to enter the final output an evil user
can enter a script that will be injected
into the website's code
the browser will then be unable to
determine whether the process code is
harmful
as a result a malicious script is
performed on the victim's browser or a
bogus form is shown to the users are you
aware of which attack this is if not do
stay till the end to find the correct
answer are you aware of which attack
this is if not please stay till the end
of the video to know the correct answer
hey everyone welcome to today's video on
application security before we move
forward subscribe to our Channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from us let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today
we start by learning about application
security and its different times we
learn about the most common
vulnerabilities in app set followed by
the importance of application Security
in today's cyber security space
next we cover some attacks against
application security and end the video
with some protection techniques to
enforce application security parameters
so let's start by learning about
application security from a Grassroots
perspective
application security which is often
known as app set protect application
software from external security threats
by utilizing security software Hardware
methodologies best practices and
different processes
organizations require application
security technologies that Safeguard all
of their programs from internal to
popular external apps on consumer mobile
phones
these Solutions must address the whole
development cycle and provide testing
after an application has been deployed
to detect possible issues application
security mechanisms are capable of
testing web pages for possible and
exploitable vulnerabilities analyzing
code and assisting the administration of
development and Safety Management
processes the testing solution must also
be simple and easy to install for system
administrators worldwide
consumers utilize hundreds of
applications daily to access
theoretically important and favored
services such as e-commerce banking
music
Etc
to be productive these professionals use
a variety of software Solutions as well
ranging from online word Checkers to
tablet based creative tools among other
things
back-end software of course exists to
automate essential operations and
processes and decreases human labor
but to make matters worse the quantity
and complexity of these apps and the
backend code is increasing
the software security problem 10 years
ago was about securing desktop apps and
static web pages that were natively
harmless and easy to scale through and
effect
because of Outsource development the
number of Legacy programs and in-house
development that uses third-party open
source and commercialized off-the-shelf
software modules the software supply
chain has become considerably more
convoluted
now that we understand application
Security on a general level let us go
through some of the different categories
or the types of application security
the three major types to be covered in
this section
web application security API security
and Cloud native application security
a web application is a program available
to the internet and it operates on a web
server the client is accessed using a
web browser
the applications by definition must
allow connections from clients across
unsecured networks this exposes them to
a variety of risks many online apps are
mission critical and include sensitive
customer data making them an attractive
Target attackers and a top concern for
any cyber security program or framework
the Advent of https which offers an
encrypted channel of communication
guards versus man in the middle attacks
or mitm attacks has addressed several
online application weaknesses
many weaknesses though still persist
many security providers have created
Solutions specifically geared to
safeguard online applications in
response to the rising challenge of web
application security
a web application firewall is an example
of a security technology meant to
identify and provide application layer
salts in the case of web applications
when it comes to apis
apis are of security flaws are the root
of many major data breaches they have
the potential to reveal sensitive data
and disrupt vital corporate processes
API security flaws include unsufficient
authentication unintended data
disclosure and a failure to apply rate
restriction which allows API abuse
the requirement for API security like
the necessity for web application
security this led to the creation of
sophisticated equipment that can
discover API vulnerabilities and protect
apis in production level
the third type is cloud native
application security
infrastructure and environments are
often built up automatically in Cloud
native apps depending on declarative
configuration which is known as
infrastructure as core or IEC
developers are tasked to developing
declarative settings and application
code both of which should be secure
because practically everything is
defined during the development stage
shifting left is even more crucial in
Cloud native setups traditional testing
techniques can help Cloud native apps
but they are insufficient
dedicated Cloud native Security
Solutions are mandatory at this point of
time which are capable of instrumenting
vessels container clusters and
serverless operations reporting on
security concerns and providing
developers with a quick feedback loop
now that we have covered the different
types of application security that is go
through some of the most common
vulnerabilities that these Frameworks
face on a daily basis
first is cryptographic failure
when data is not adequately safeguarded
in transit and addressed cryptographic
failures which are formerly known as
sensitive data exposures occur it has
the potential to reveal credentials
health information credit card details
and personal information as well
depending on the type of data being
protected in that particular case
injection attacks six attackers can use
injection burner abilities to convey
malicious information to a web
application interpreter it has the
potential to assemble and execute this
data on the server
SQL injection is a popular type of
injection which I've already covered in
an introduction for this video
another major vulnerability are outdated
components vulnerable and Auto Trade
components Encompass any vulnerability
caused by obsolete or unmaintained
software it can happen if you construct
or even use an application without first
learning about its core components and
versions
authentication failures
identification and authentication
failure which are previously known as
broken authentication Encompass any
security issue involving user identities
identity attacks and exploitation may be
avoided by implementing secure session
Administration authentication and
validation for all identities in their
organization
in the next section let us cover some of
the protection mechanisms employed by
cyber security firms and third-party
automated software to prevent the
application layer from being bombarded
with SQL injections and other attacks
the first is a web application firewall
or Waf
a web application firewall monitors and
Builders HTTP traffic within a web
application and the World Wide Web
application firewall architecture does
not address all risks but it may be used
in conjunction with other defense
mechanisms it can be used to the
portfolio of Security Solutions to
provide a comprehensive defense against
diverse attack roads
it is a protocol layer 7 protection in
the open systems interconnection or the
OSI model paradigm that helps different
online application against attacks such
as cross-site scripting cross-site fraud
skill injection and file infusion
unlike a proxy server which conceals the
identity of client computers by an
intermediary a wire functions as a
reverse proxy shielding the server from
exposure it acts as a barrier in front
of a web application protecting it from
the internet so clients must pass
through the web application firewall
before they can access the application
the second is threat assessment
a list of sensitive assets to save guard
will assist you in understanding the
threat to your firm and how to minimize
them considering how a hacker can
infiltrate an application if the
existing security protections are in
place and whether additional tools or
defense capabilities are required it's
also crucial to keep your security
expectations in check
nothing is impenetrable even if the most
stringent security measures
it would be best if you were realistic
about what you believe your team can
handle in the long term when pushed to
aggressively safety regulations and
procedures might be disregarded remember
that safety is a lengthy and time-taking
project that requires the collaboration
of other employees and sometimes even
your customers
the next topic is privilege management
limiting privileges is vital especially
for Mission critical and sensitive
systems the least privileged principle
states that access to programs and data
should be limited to those who require
them when they require them
for two reasons the least privileged
principle is absolutely critical
the first is that hackers May compromise
less privileged accounts and ensuring
they do not acquire access to highly
sensitive systems is critical
the second is that internal digits are
equally harmful as external adversaries
if insiders go bad it's critical to
ensure they never have more power than
they need minimizing the half that they
may be able to cause to the organization
network security is a set of
technologies that protects the usability
and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network
its architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it
effective network security strategies
employ multiple lines of defense that
are scalable and automated each
defensive layer here enforces a set of
security policies which are determined
by the administrator beforehand
and accessibility of the data and the
network
the every company or organization that
handles a large amount of data has a
degree of solutions against many cyber
threats the most basic example of
network security is password protection
it has the network the user chooses
the recently network security has become
the central topic of cyber security with
many organizations involving
applications from people with skills in
this area it is crucial for both
personal and professional networks most
houses with high speed internet have one
or more wireless routers which can be
vulnerable to attacks if they are not
adequately secured
data loss theft and sabotages may be
decreased with the usage of a strong
network security system
the workstations are protected from
hazardous spiral thanks to network
security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network
by dividing information into various
sections encrypting these portions and
transferring them over separate Pathways
network security infrastructure offers
multiple levels of protection to thwart
man in the middle attacks preventing
situations like eavesdropping among
other harmful attacks it has become
increasingly difficult in today's
hyper-connected environment as more
corporate applications migrate to both
public and private talks
additionally modern applications are
also frequently virtualized and
dispersed across several locations some
outside the physical control of the IT
team
Network traffic and infrastructure must
be protected in these cases since
assaults on businesses are increasing
every single day
they now understood the basics of
network security
but we need to understand how network
security works in the next section in
slightly more detail
network security revolves around two
processes authentication and
authorization
the first person which is authentication
is similar to access path which ensure
that only those who have the right to
enter a building
in other words authentication checks and
verifies that it is indeed the user
belonging to the network who is trying
to access or enter it thereby preventing
unauthorized introductions
next comes authorization
this process decides the level of access
provided to the recently authenticated
user
for example Network admin needs access
to the entire network whereas those
working within it probably need access
to any certain areas within the network
based on the network user's role the
process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization
today's Network architecture is complex
and faces a threat environment that is
always changing and attackers that are
always trying to find an exploit
vulnerabilities
these vulnerabilities can exist in many
areas including devices data
applications users and locations
for this reason many Network Security
Management tools and applications are in
use today that address individual
threats
when it's just a few minutes of down
times can cause widespread disruption
and massive damage to an organization's
bottom line and reputation it is
essential that these protection measures
are in place beforehand
now that I know a little about network
security and it's working let's cover to
the different types of network security
the fundamental tenet of network
security is the layering of protection
for massive networks and stored data
that ensure the acceptance of rules and
regulations
and Suppose there are three types the
first of which is physical security
the next being Technical and the third
being administrative
let's look into physical security post
this is the most basic level that
includes protecting data and network
through unauthorized Personnel from
acquiring control over the
confidentiality of the network
this include external peripherals and
routers that might be used for cable
connections the same can be achieved by
using devices like biometric systems
physical security is critical especially
for small businesses that do not have
many resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large firms
when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions
this kind fulfills two functions one is
defense against unauthorized users the
other is a difference against manipulate
actions
the last category is Administrative this
level of network security protects user
Behavior like how the permission has
been granted and how the authorization
process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protect it through all the attacks
this level also suggests necessary
amendments that have to be done to the
infrastructure
I think there's all the basics that we
need to cover on network security in
which our next topic we're going to go
through two mediums of network security
which are the transport layer and the
application layer
so transport layer is a way to secure
information as it is carried over the
Internet with users browsing websites
emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with the
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties to the connected in
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications
the connection employs lighter symmetric
cryptography to save bandwidth and
processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface over app layer security can lead
to a performance and stability issues
data theft and in some cases the network
being taken down examples of application
layer attacks include distributed denial
of service attacks or pdos attacks HTTP
plugs SQL injections cross-site
scripting
Etc
most organizations have an arsenal of
application layer security protections
to combat these and more such as web
application firewalls secure web Gateway
Services
Etc
now that you have the theory behind
network security has been covered in
detail let us go through some of the
tools that can be used to enforce these
network security policies
the first two to be covered in this
section is a firewall a firewall is a
type of network security device that
keeps track of incoming and outgoing
Network traffic and it decides which
traffic to allow ordinand in accordance
to a set of security rules
for more than 25 years firewalls have
served Network Securities first line of
defense they provide a barrier between
trustworthy internal protected and
regulated networks from Shady external
networks like the internet at some
points
the next tool which can be used to
bolster network security is a virtual
private Network or VPN for sure
it's an encrypted connection between a
device and a network via the Internet
the encrypted connection is the secure
transmission of sensitive data it makes
it impossible for unauthorized parties
to eavesdrop on the traffic and enables
remote work for the user the usage of
VPN technology is common in both
corporate and personal networks next we
cover the importance of inclusion
prevention systems in network security
or IPS Frameworks
an intrusion prevention system is a
network security tool that continually
scans the network for harmful activity
and responds to it when it does occur by
reporting blocking or discarding it
it can be either Hardware or software
it's more sophisticated than an
intuition detection system or an IDs
framework which can just warn an
administrator and merely identify
harmful activities while in the case of
an IPS it actually takes against that
activity
the next tool in this section and the
final one are going to be behavioral
Analytics
Behavior analytics focus more on the
statistics that are being carried over
and stored through months and years of
usage
on some kind of similar pattern is noted
by the ID administrator can detect some
kind of attack the similar attacks can
be stopped and the security can be
further enhanced
but now that you have covered all that
we need to know about network security
the necessary tools and different types
Etc let's go to the benefits of network
security as a port
the first which is protection against
external threats the objective for cyber
assaults can be as varied as the
Defenders themselves
although they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and cohort the attacks are
getting a strong cyber security posture
that considers routine software updates
May assist Works in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry points
the next benefit is protection against
internal threats the human aspect
continues to be the cyber security
system's weakest link inside the risk
can originate from current or former
workers third party vendors or even
trusted partners and they can be
unintentional careless or downright even
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote locations can make
it easier for these kind of threats to
go undetected until it's too late
however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
ranges may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive disasters
the third benefit is increase
productivity it's nearly impossible for
employees to function when Network and
personal devices are slowed to a crawl
by viruses and other cyber attacks
during the operation of website and for
the company to run you must
significantly minimize violations and
the amount of downtime required to fix
the breach by implementing various cyber
security measures such as enhanced
firewalls by the scanning and automatic
backups
employee identification of possible
email phishing schemes suspicious links
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training
another benefit is brand trust and
reputation
customer retention is one of the most
crucial elements in business development
customers today place a premium on
maintaining brand loyalty through a
strong cyber security stance since this
is the fastest way to get other
businesses back get referrals and sell
more tickets overall
additionally it helps manufacturers get
on the vendor list with bigger companies
as a part of the supply chain which is
only as strong as its weakest link
this opens possibilities for potential
future endeavors and development with
the rise in censorship and general fear
over privacy loss consumer security is
at an all-time high risk technology has
made our life so much easier while
putting up a decent Target on our
personal information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
Safeguard our data and be up to date
with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world so hey everyone this is Baba from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on cryptography but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography meet Anne Anne wanted to
look for a decent discount on the latest
iPhone she started searching on the
internet and founder rather Shady
website that offered a 50 discount on
the first purchase once and submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was
their HTTP webpage instead of an https
one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers Hatcher used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employs cryptography
our iPhone enthusiasts could have
avoided this particular incident this is
why it's never recommended to visit
unknown websites or share any personal
information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today
we take a look into what cryptography is
and how it works we learn where
cryptography is being used in our daily
lives and how we are benefiting from it
then we will understand the different
types of cryptography and their
respective users
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
encryption in action
let's Now understand what cryptography
is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is a primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply run is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text the only
ones who can are the people who know how
to decrypt the coded word thereby
reversing the process of encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text to encrypt the
message we use certain algorithms that
serve a single purpose of scrambling the
data to make them unreadable without the
necessary tools these algorithms are
called ciphers they are a set of
detailed steps to be carried out one
after the other to make sure the data
becomes as unreadable as possible until
it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
ciphertext and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit more than 65 billion
messages are sent on WhatsApp every day
all of which are secured thanks to
end-to-end encryption
there is a huge Market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice
they are
symmetric encryption
asymmetric encryption
and hashing let's find out how much we
have understood until now do you
remember the difference between a cipher
and ciphertext leave your answers in the
comments and before we proceed if you
find this video interesting make sure to
give it a thumbs up before moving ahead
let's look at symmetric encryption first
symmetric encryption uses a single key
for both the encryption and decryption
of data it is comparatively less secure
than asymmetric encryption but much
faster it is a compromise that has to be
embraced in order to deliver data as
fast as possible without leaving
information completely vulnerable
this type of encryption is used when
data rests on servers and identifies
Personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times
Caesar Cipher Enigma machine are both
symmetric encryption examples that we
will look into further
for example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob she can apply a
substitution Cipher or a shift Cipher to
encrypt the message but Bob must be
aware of the same key itself so he can
decrypt it when he finds it necessary to
read the entire message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into ciphertext stream
ciphers convert the plain text into
ciphertext one bit at a time instead of
resorting to breaking them up into
bigger chunks
in today's world the most widely used
symmetric encryption algorithm is AES
256 that stands for advanced encryption
standard which has a key size of 256 bit
with 128 bit and 196 bit key sizes also
being available other primitive
algorithms like the data encryption
standard that is the Des the triple data
encryption standard 3des and Blowfish
have all fallen out of favor due to the
rise of AES AES chops UPS the data into
blocks and performs 10 plus rounds of
obscuring and substituting the message
to make it unreadable
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
has a double whammy at its disposal
there are two different keys at play
here a public key and a private key the
public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key
after receiving the message Bob uses his
own private key to decrypt the data this
way nobody can intercept the message in
between transmissions and there is no
need for any secure key exchange for
this to work since the encryption is
done with the public key and the
decryption is another private key that
no one except Bob has access to both the
keys are necessary to read the full
message
there is also a reverse scenario where
we can use a private key for encryption
and the public key for decryption a
server can sign non-confidential
information using its private key and
anyone who has its public key can
decrypt the message this mechanism also
proves that the sender is authenticated
and there is no problem with the origin
of the information
RSA encryption is the most widely used
asymmetric encryption standard it is
named after its Founders revised Shamir
and Edelman and it uses block ciphers
that separate the data into blocks and
obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than AES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time since asymmetric
encryption takes longer to decrypt large
amounts of data the full information is
encrypted using a single key that is
symmetric encryption that single key is
then transmitted to the receiver using
asymmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the diffie-helpman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into
the third variant of cryptography is
termed as hashing
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of data beyond recognition it
gives an output of fixed size which is
known as the hash value of the original
data or just hash in general the
calculations that do the job of messing
up the data collection form the hash
function they are generally not
reversible without resilient Brute Force
mechanisms and are very helpful when
storing data on website servers that
need not be stored in plain text for
example many websites store your account
passwords in a hashed format so that not
even the administrator can read your
credentials when a user tries to log in
they can compare the entered passwords
hash value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
authentication since the function will
always return the same value for the
same input
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
Julius Caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table a spy can't decipher the
original message at first glance for
example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use the substitution
shift of plus 2 a becomes c b becomes D
and so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus 3
becomes dww d f n this Cipher has been
appropriately named the Caesar Cipher
which is one of the most widely used
algorithms
the Enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic Cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the Nazi German armies in
the world wars they were used to protect
confidential political military and
administrative information and it
consisted of three or more rotors that
scramble the original message depending
on the machine's State at that time the
decryption is similar but it needs both
machines to stay in the same state
before passing the cipher text so that
we receive the same plain text message
let's take a look at how our data is
protected while we browse the internet
thanks to cryptography here we have a
web-based tool that will help us
understand the process of RSA encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the ciphertext in
order to get the plain text back
as we already know RSA encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetrically cryptography
that basically implies that we have two
keys at play here a public key and a
private key
typically the public key is used by the
sender to encrypt the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well
in RSA we have the choice of key size we
can select any key from a 512 bit to
1024 bit all the way up to a 4096 bit
key the longer the key length the more
complex the encryption process becomes
and thereby strengthening the ciphertext
although with added security more
complex functions take longer to perform
the same operations on similar size of
data we have to keep a balance between
both speed and strength because the
strongest encryption algorithms are of
no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024 bit key over here
now we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operate on pass freezes the tool we are
using right now generates this
pseudorandom keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other
they cannot be substituted with any
other key and in order to encrypt the
original message or decrypt the
ciphertext this pair must be kept
together the public key is then sent to
the sender and the receiver keeps the
private key with himself in this
scenario let's try and encrypt the word
simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over here
the cipher we are using right now is
plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well
once you click on encrypt we can see the
ciphertext being generated over here
the pseudorandom generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plain text will
trigger a completely different
ciphertext this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from Brute Force
methods now that we are done with the
encryption process let's take a look at
the decryption part
the receiver gets this Cipher text from
the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
be used to decrypt the message since
they are mathematically linked we paste
the private key here and select the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption process
once we click decrypt you can see the
original plain text we had decided to
encrypt this sums up the entire process
of RSA encryption and decryption
now some people use it the other way
around we also have the option of using
the private key to encrypt information
and the public key to decrypt it this is
done mostly to validate the origin of
the message since the keys only work in
pairs if a different private key is used
to encrypt the message the public key
cannot decrypt it conversely if the
public key is able to decrypt the
message it must have been encrypted with
the right private key and hence the
rightful owner here we just have to take
the private key and use that to encrypt
the plain text and select the same in
this checkbox as well you can see we
have generated a completely new Cipher
text
this ciphertext will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for decryption
let's select the correct checkbox and
decrypt
and we still get the same output
now let's take a look at practical
example of encryption in the real world
we all use the internet on a daily basis
and many are aware of the implications
of using unsafe websites let's take a
look at Wikipedia here pretty standard
https website where the edge stands for
secured let's take a look at how it
secures the data
Wireshark is the world's foremost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use this software to see the traffic
that is leaving a machine and to
understand how vulnerable it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to Wikipedia
[Music]
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website with
okay once we get into it a little you
can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request
these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice versa
as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way
to put this in perspective
let's take a look at another website
which is a HTTP web page
this has no encryption enabled from the
server end which makes it vulnerable to
attacks there is a login form here which
needs legitimate user credentials in
order to Grant access
let's enter a random pair of credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data's transfer
unsurprisingly we weren't able to get
into the platform instead we can see the
data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand
what request this website is sending
these are the requests being sent by the
HTTP login form to the internet if we
check here
see whatever username and password that
we are entering we can easily see it
with the Wireshark
now we used a dummy pair of credentials
if we select the right data packet we
can find the correct credentials if any
website had asked for a payment
information or a legitimate credentials
it have been really easy to get a hold
of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid HTTP
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online
there are two types of encryption in
cryptography
symmetric key cryptography
and asymmetric key cryptography both of
these categories have their pros and
cons and differ only by the
implementation as we wrap up our
exploration of cyber security
fundamentals we hope you have enjoyed
this insightful Journey should you need
any assistance PPT project code and
other resources used in this session
please let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be happy to help you as soon as
possible until next time thank you and
keep learning stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you